bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce 8e
de finale entre André Keane et Aronian
qui commence tout juste à l'instant donc
je pense qu'on va directement vous
mettre les caméras
pour plus avoir un petit peu ce qu'il se
passe
alors la partie on commence à l'argument
chez moi le lien alors ça commence ça va
commencer
vont commencer à l'instant et on a du
coup à la caméra on a harmonyan avec les
Blancs contre André Keane donc je pense
que avec
je dois t'entendre deux fois en fait
je pense c'est force
c'est très probable et voilà ça y est
d'habitude tu as une magnifique voix et
puis là
le côté numérique déforme ta voix et je
trouve ça terrible est-ce que c'est
mieux du coup ouais c'est c'est
magnifique alors du coup du coup je vous
rappelle un petit peu le format du mal
donc on va voir 1h30 de 5 + 1
donc il y aura une pause au milieu au
bout de 45 minutes ensuite on aura
une heure de de 3 + 1 pour finir avec
une demi-heure de Bullet en une plus
jeune voilà le grand n'importe quoi à la
fin et avant de partir un peu plus
sérieuses ça va vite mais c'est
relativement facile à commenter on
s'amuse bien avec stouf à suivre cela et
après dès qu'on attaque les les
bullettes surtout à la fin c'est plus
chaud mais pour les joueurs aussi c'est
une grosse performance de jouer autant
de parties de ce niveau là à ses pense
là qui se réduisent petit à petit donc
salut
approche un peu de micro alors du coup
avant que le score commence un petit peu
à s'élever etc
Kevin j'ai la question qui est toujours
importante tu sais tu sais qu'à chaque
fois nous on a des Paris lors de cette
image et bien sûr là en ce moment j'ai
énormément de dettes j'ai même pu pas pu
aller de régler mes dettes du randoms
mais surtout de notre dernier
d'un dernier match vécu par par
procuration où j'avais choisi de
soutenir mon camarade de club
Erika easy que tu voulais au départ
soutenir finalement John Lennon tu avais
choisi beau joueur de
d'aller sur carwana pour me laisser mon
partenaire de club et c'est finalement
pas une surprise mais quand même au vu
du démarrage du match au vu de l'âge des
deux protagonistes on pensait qu'il
était légèrement favoris même si les
statistiques indiquaient le contraire et
finalement bah tu as eu raison de
changer tout puisque c'est Caruana qui
l'a emporté et assez sèchement sur la
fin et du coup ce soir on se retrouve
avec Andreï Kin et et bien sûr les von a
rognan et là cette fois-ci avait choisi
en avant c'est normal les von a rognant
donc moi je me retrouve à Dimitri André
clean mais
les chances sont assez proches sauf oui
non là c'est un petit peu on va dire
plus équilibré le match franchement il
est pas clair du tout alors c'est vrai
que la dernière fois quand même
plus en vrai mais c'est pas clair c'est
pas clair les deux dernières parties
c'était match nul jusqu'en Bullet et
jusqu'à la toute fin sauf
un spécialiste du Blitz et Bullet
[Musique]
il est bon comme dans toutes les dans
toutes les cadences il aime beaucoup le
Blitz et franchement bah écoute on va
voir un peu ce qui se passe
dans tous les cas ça s'équilibrer et
puis donc tout à l'heure on m'annonçait
que aronia et ben ça faisait trois ans
d'affilée ou quand on a filé je sais
plus qui le perd tout le temps en il
s'est pris une petite tactique
d'ailleurs à l'instant je crois stouf
pour fêter son entrée
ok d'accord donc ce qui se passe en fait
c'est que quand tu prends cette rock tu
as mes chèques d'apprendre ça tu me dis
ça
ouais c'est ça c'est ça c'était
et ça va gagner une pièce donc un
royaume qui perd une pièce très très
vite
quand même donc du coup ok moi ok mais
c'est peut-être pas si grave parce qu'il
est comme des cases noires qui vont être
quand même mais c'est assez rigolo déjà
ce qui se passe
en tout cas on voit les deux jours sont
chauds
et ça c'est intéressant
dans tous les cas ça va être un match
vraiment très très intéressant du coup
pour par rapport au Paris je te propose
qu'on va exactement comme on a fait la
dernière fois
on se parie deux subs par 7 exactement
et puis
[Musique]
et puis ensuite
tu vois j'ai noté c'est hyper bien c'est
facile de se rappeler il y a donc un
maximum si vraiment on passe une
mauvaise soirée on peut se prendre 10-0
la dernière fois que j'ai déjà pris 8 2
tu vois c'était pas c'était pas une
grande déjà mais voilà au max c'est 10-0
déjà tu prends 10-0
tu tu rentres un peu penaud quoi
donc ok donc en tout cas
un match qui promet en tout cas à être
vraiment très très intéressant et salut
à toi belge et salut j'aime pas perdre
salut les gars
donc là il y a pion de plus pour pour
les noirs avec une meilleure structure
mais vous voyez que le fou on s'est
lutte un peu du mal à bouger grâce au
plan F5 qui peut pas jouer aussi et il
peut y avoir sur le long terme des
problèmes comme surcases blanches avec
le enfin
qui va venir en C5 pour empêcher le rock
Latour qui va venir en E1 pour attaquer
la dame le son à 5 aussi jouer F6 pour
consolider le 5 très très vite alors
d'ailleurs
les intrusions sur case noire et fixer
le pion F5 qui aurait pu jouer F6 pour
compliquer la position et je vois j'aime
pas perdre qui nous dit eh les gars sur
Youtube on nous propose de suivre mvl
nepo on n'a pas la main sur Youtube mais
on peut relayer
est-ce que c'est encore sur Youtube tout
ça parce que faut bah tiens si Nathan
m'écoute c'est un double retransmission
sur Youtube sauf ce que j'aurais
sûrement mais malheureusement moi je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas accès à tout ça si
nathan est là qui m'entend et Ben et ben
c'est le moment de de changer ça
mais malheureusement nous on peut pas
toucher au titre que ce soit sur twitch
sur youtube
il y a un mais ça va être vite réglé
sans doute vous allez voir j'aime pas
perdre tu vas surveiller la réactivité
de Nathan à la baguette
technique
bon et là nos deux joueurs ça a l'air
sympa pour les Noirs ça non
mais pas serein non
et puis et puis voilà mais en vrai alors
d'ailleurs Kevin je voulais te annoncer
quelque chose alors j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle pour toi dis-moi on m'a demandé
de mettre la barre d'évaluation
c'est vrai ouais d'ailleurs je vais
devoir la rajouter sur le chéquier je
pense voilà parce que
la barre ne fait que confirmer
c'est pas si simple mais tu vois encore
une fois on n'a pas
nous on n'a pas les coups on va faire
tout le tout le stream sans avoir les
variantes et sans avoir tout ça on va
juste avoir la barre d'évaluation qui va
qui va monter on peut dire que la barre
d'évaluation c'est quand même une grosse
indication pour nous ça nous aide
énormément si les joueurs l'avaient la
qualité des parties qui est déjà énorme
elle s'en ressentirées encore à la
hausse oui parce que du coup si je
regarde tu sais qu'il y a un truc à
trouver voilà mais après voilà c'est
vrai que pour vous qui suivez
l'événement en tête c'est plus sympa
s'il y a une barre d'événements et puis
du coup
ça peut être un peu plus excitant quoi
c'est vrai que même nous des fois
l'évaluation un peu du mal à à vous la
donner et donc après bon bah là on fait
on essaie de faire un petit peu dans la
pédagogie quand on va commander ça mais
aussi de l'avoir aussi en termes de
chaud quoi donc
c'est que quand les valeurs à Sion est
entre 0 et 1 on trouve ça chaud voilà
entre 0 et 1 il y a rien de fait c'est
compliqué même des fois arrivé même à
avoir
trois mais qui est compliqué tu vois
bien sûr là par exemple je préfère
largement avoir les blancs tu vois parce
qu'il y a un pion de plus chez le noir
il a mis deux pions plus chez les Noirs
mais le roi est encore au centre il peut
pas rocker tour des 6 tours D1 et il y a
un gros problème je sais pas il est bien
de faire de la même fête donc je sais
pas quel est son idée mais il a intérêt
de vite de trouver une idée parce que
ça commence vraiment
dans ma chatte peut-être
une reprend F6 donc c'est pas possible
donc ça va être ça va être compliqué
déjà là je crois qu'il a joué des coups
un peu
il a été bouffé à deux
fois
il a le matos
avec un gros score très grosse score
donc là je pense qu'il va le C5 et son
idée sûrement c'est de donner des pions
pour activer ce flou plus tard après il
faut s'attendre
je pense qu'il a prévu sur
[Musique]
quelque chose pour lutter contre le foot
couleur opposé c'est pour ça qu'il a
donné le pion il a redonné un pion ce
qu'il y en a beaucoup d'avance
jolie
et 27 secondes voilà
5 attention
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle on voit que
c'est
dès qu'on rentre dans les dans les 20
secondes c'est quand même la loterie
ça fait peut-être nul ouais ça serait
pas illogique dans cette position
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as mangé pion est-ce que
toujours pour gagner avec ton pion s'est
passé j'ai pas l'impression que sur
cette première partie soit parti pour
on va voir en tout cas ça a l'air de
répéter quand même
[Musique]
ça a l'air de répéter et ça fait rire
ils sont pas mécontents tous les deux
peut-être de s'échauffer quoi
et du meilleur parce que André King
devait être pas mal dans le début
objectivement le problème c'est qu'à
cette cadence là sa position est un peu
infernale d'ailleurs qui disait qu'en
pratique toi tu préférais les blancs
alors que le module nous indiquait qu'il
y avait un avantage il y avait un
avantage noir quand je dis le module
c'est la barre d'évaluation mais pas
facile à convertir avec des lettres
voilà donc c'est compliqué finalement et
même les joueurs ne savent pas s'il y a
assez ils ont pas de barre d'évaluation
[Musique]
donc la rente 2 a commencé enfin de
deuxième partie plutôt a commencé et ça
c'est marrant parce que moi j'écoutais
dans une petite oreillettes là parce que
j'ai les joueurs qui sont là avec
l'arbitre et en fait les joueurs qui
savaient pas qu'il devait qui devait se
remet
et donc les deux jours attendaient que
la partie commence mais en fait
leur dit
remascov qui me dit
salut à toi rcka est pas mal 10 euros tu
passes sous l'échiquier Kevin passer sur
mon bureau à 10-0 déjà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à toi ouais c'est vrai que j'ai
peut-être oublié de couper le son moi je
l'avais pas je l'avais pas qui est sur
alors du coup c'est quoi le son que
j'aurais coupé je sais pas lequel parce
que j'ai audio une poutre et au lieu
je t'entends plus je crois
absolument pas parce que je vois pas non
je pense que je peux rien y faire
écouter vous entendrez l'arbitre
et puis c'est très bien c'est mieux
c'est un total Immersion tu devrais dire
merci
alors du coup cette position
assez classique qu'on a qu'on a quand
même vu très souvent à ce niveau-là
des sortes de
mais en même temps on a retardé notre
développement du coup le temps de
pousser les pions
position assez équilibrée généralement
donc est-ce que tu prends en Satis
d'ailleurs
contre option du centre sauf que il y a
quand même l'avance de développement
ils ont joué le fouet assez rapidement
parce que ils étaient sous-développés
comment est-ce que je pourrais profiter
là d'ailleurs de l'avance de
développement ici pour C8 pour mettre un
petit science sur la cavaler des caisses
j'ai pas envie de laisser le
[Musique]
c'était logique sur un coup comme tours
8 dans ces cadences là évitez de laisser
les rayons lasers sur des pièces un
nombre protégées soit attaquer une fois
défendues une fois des pièces
vulnérables pour les enlever quoi et ça
c'est le principe de la prophylaxie
qu'on voit qu'il y a une menace qui peut
arriver et ben au lieu de de calculer
etc dans les avances rapide essayez de
bouger vos pièces comme ça vous êtes sûr
que vous anticipez tous les problèmes
qui puissent arriver dans votre partie
vis-à-vis entre la tour et le cavalier
avec l'aide menace là-dessus ben en fait
je peux défendre et pour c'est un Dame
des deux mais je peux aussi bouger ma
pièce et qui ok il y a plus de problème
maintenant allez avec des cadences
rapides comme ça on n'a pas le temps de
tout calculer de toute façon donc du
coup il faut essayer de le simple en
fait voilà
on sait tous pris de façon en fait sinon
vous apprendrez à la dure vous allez
vous faire avoir et du coup ben vous
réajusterez mais autant effectivement
écouter le Conseil l'appliquer
il y a un monde que se passe-t-il
c'est le coup
en fait les noirs sont marrant
développement donc ils veulent profiter
ainsi il se dit bon d'accord je mange
faut prendre à me prendre pour ces deux
sans doute
bancal l'idée était énorme parce que
l'idée c'est de faire B5 pour valoriser
le 2 contre un lalda mais gagner la
carte C4 bon c'est c'est top plus tard
comme B4 pour essayer d'avoir un peu
passé je suis qu'avec un C4 et du coup
j'ai réussi à améliorer la position
considérablement grâce à la 6 B5 qui
d'ailleurs le plus raciste pas mangeable
parce qu'il y avait toujours celui qui
arrivait en fin de variante
quand même parce qu'il a mis une grosse
pression dans la première et dans la
deuxième et ben il a déjà deux minutes
d'avance
il sort des bons coups et on sent qu'il
est bien préparé on sent qu'il est
confortable dans ses ouvertures dans
tout ça il mange de cacahuète tout à
l'heure et il a l'air de il a l'air de
ouais tranquille quoi
c'est difficile de trouver l'objectif
des blancs parce que pousser la majorité
centrale c'est un classique on a du mal
à le faire à 4 c'est très bizarre
parce que peut-être B4 on peut jouer
avec la mamie deck tout à l'heure c'est
c'est dangereux on a on lâche à 6 mais
on a
alors ça va très vite
on claque la pièce pour manger
sacrifice de qualité mais il met deux
pièces moi il a une tour sèche de moi
mais il y a 2 pièces
il jouait à une vitesse tellement folle
[Musique]
c'est un coup quand même faut pas
oublier qu'elle avait aussi un coup et
donc les gens ont des qualités de plus
avec quand même
C5 je pense qui était plus fort mais bon
de changer les pièces c'est tout à fait
normal
donc c'est pas facile pour André King je
comprends aussi
ça a joué une vitesse de cinglé là
séquence qui était quand même
extrêmement compliqué je crois que on a
vu de toute façon là qu'il avait raté
quelque chose et du coup
parce que le fou il est pas vraiment en
privé il y a bonne chance que les vannes
prennent le premier point parce que même
si la position est très soluble chez des
blancs et sont actives donc je vais
réussir à doubler effectivement sauf la
deuxième rangée la tour avis
pour le mettre du couloir à deux
et ça sent le début de sub dans cette
partie
là c'est terrible c'est terrible je suis
je fais déjà grise
[Musique]
pour changer les pièces
non mais surtout qu'il a pas été très
convaincant André King il a une minute
de moins la pendule
très très rapidement
j'ai trois donc là on va on va voir pour
ça
ça crée des délais entre vous deux
comment ça un sacré délai entre nous
deux
comment ça il y a des
parce que nous on s'entend pas on n'a
pas le retour forcément
qu'à la je peux vous dire que c'est
extrêmement dur là pour
écrire 5 minutes en moins et ça poubelle
comme on dit après ça va très vite il y
a des petits tricks qui peuvent arriver
à n'importe quel moment dans ces
positions
F6 cavalid et 3 donc la tour à deux on
va essayer de tricoter un petit peu et
de choses
de l'adversaire
apparemment tout va bien nous prenons
de très très loin
c'est possible
ça peut être cool avec aussi H5 jeu
simple de d'arrognan la très technique
ça rajoute des problèmes sur le roi la
tour est maximisée le cavalier maximisé
on va améliorer notre roi on crée une
faiblesse en H3 puis je crois qu'il peut
un jour être perdu faire attention à ça
un moment
voilà
qui est qui est
donc quand on donne des cases un petit
peu
de 4
on peut jouer un coup comme cavalier C3
pour
ce kb4 qu'il a choisi pour intercepter
alors voyons en fait ça donne une pièce
qu'on a l'impression mais en fait quand
cavaler pour Praille ici je pourrais
manger en deux parce que vous sera coupé
donc c'est puis voyez les secondes c'est
graines plus que 25 secondes 5
je pense qu'on va manger non ramenez le
roi ici peut-être
il y a des thèmes de tour des quatre
tours des trois aussi
[Musique]
le roi et après on amène pas assez
facilement mais tour des deux il se
Leroy et après on a mal noir
va monter il y aura plus qu'à
[Musique]
technique là il va sacrifier la ils
peuvent sacrifier maintenant ça a l'air
logique
et montre le roi il mange le pion à 5 et
ça va être abandon de André qui dans
cette partie du coup qui
[Musique]
a vraiment subi cette partie
trop trop dur
allez
[Musique]
on repart avec erranian blanc dans cette
partie de 5 + 2
bon on voit que pour l'instant il est
devant hein rognon très clairement
la première il a été devant bon il a
raté je pense l'attaque honnêtement je
suis pas sûr qu'il avait anticipé
jusqu'au bout sauf mais
du coup c'était c'était quand même pas
tip top et c'est reparti pour la même
style d'ouverture en plus
tu la connaisses du monde en 2009 c'est
bien ça
il y a tout le temps
à partir il y avait eu cavalué 6
cavalier prend et c'était
plus comment c'était le côté
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire pour
contrôler les centres et comme la dame
est en D3
là ils en ont profité pour éclater les
centres donc ça c'est un truc assez
standard ou généralement les Blancs ont
très peu de chance de perdre sa position
c'est assez plat
ça j'avais travaillé avec les Blancs
[Musique]
excessive des cinq ça a conduit au pion
isolé généralement et après on a un
travail
[Musique]
contre un pion isolé généralement ce
qu'on va essayer de faire c'est c'est
bloquer déjà ce pion et essayer après de
d'échanger les pièces pour les blancs
[Musique]
aussi F3 tourner un et c'est le même
pression un peu sur le plan de 5 et
salut à toi route
il a réussi à lui mettre le pion C3
c'est un contre jeu parce qu'au final
beaucoup de fois quand je fais réussir à
manger des seins et ben aussi ces trois
en échange donc c'est pas dit que
vraiment les blancs arrivent ici à
profiter de ça maintenant maintenant il
y a un autre problème c'est aussi le
clouage sans cavalier
si par contre j'arrive à manger là ça
fait quand même lecture chez les noirs
qui est quand même sacrément sacrément
et j'ai 5 ouvrez la case noire sans
avoir le foot qui reste noir chez toi
c'est très dangereux faut que j'ai trois
ou cinq et il te manque à votre case
noire quand même dans le château
donc c'est dangereux
est-ce que peut-être à 5 pour faire
tourner tant pis je préfère avoir la
structure avec les trois pions aller le
droit c'est pas très grave
enfin c'est pas très grave on a vu mieux
mais
je veux bien à 5 tours
[Musique]
parce que si il joue pas dynamisme
mais bon ça peut aller vite à ce jeu là
on l'a vu
jouera plus spontané dans des cadences
dans des cadences plus courtes donc tour
C8
est-ce que comme C4 est possible mais je
suis pas sûr que vraiment
on a envie de changer pour moi
ça montre bien qu'on a pas l'ordinateur
soyez bien que on me on ne commande pas
avec l'ordinateur on commence avec nos
têtes ah tu voulais parler des
structures de pions sauf
je voulais essayer de déstabiliser
l'option des cinq sur le cavalier
essayer on aime le beau jeu
donc
là on a réussi à troquer le pion à votre
pioncer qui était faible
[Musique]
il y a un pion passé avec le foot casse
blanche c'est intéressant la paire de
foutage de la même
et l'option toujours ici qui est faible
à rognon qui fait vraiment un très très
bon début de match en tout cas hyper
propre
et du coup on se demande un petit peu
comment il va faire pour pour gérer ça
en dream
ce qui est impressionnant joue très vite
mais après ça peut peut-être pas si mal
j'ai les pièces je sais pas
[Musique]
j'aime pas laisser ça quand même ça me
dérange un peu
même tour à trois
je crois aussi des fois
[Musique]
office de mauvais bloqueurs oui elle est
pas vraiment là pour bloque elle bloque
mais c'est pas vraiment son rôle ici là
il voulait plutôt contrôler les cases
noires je pense et essayer de faire un
truc fou là-haut mais oui oui c'est vrai
que c'est pas le meilleur blogueur Adam
généralement c'est le cavalière
parce que dans ces trois c'est quand
même un peu énervant on a toujours un il
était vraiment bien pour aller pousser
le pion a ça allait plus là
et du coup c'est un peu plus difficile
c'est quand même favorable au blanc
encore
mais on aurait King il devait pas être
loin de subir énormément les choses je
pense que c'est un petit conseil
[Musique]
parce que bah il sait qu'il est beaucoup
mieux mais il veut trouver quelque chose
pour valoriser son avantage et bah ça
crève pas les yeux la valorisation ici
sauf
clairement pas clairement pas ça reste
ça reste pas clair
que manger il y a cavalier franc qui va
perdre par défaut donc je pense qu'il
faut pas bouger la dame il faut attendre
de se faire manger rejoins
[Musique]
plus rien ça sert à rien malheureusement
parce que il va manger là je vais manger
du Fou et après le faire caresser 3 et
ça va transposer tatouin c'est le coup
mais il vient de faire tourner donc
une erreur c'est après des fois il faut
accepter ses erreurs et essayer de bah
écoute
parce que quand vous voyez un mec comme
ça qui a très très bien joué depuis le
départ prendre plus d'une minute sur un
coup comme ça c'est énorme la réflexion
une minute 43 sauf 1040 exactement ça
bloque le fou et tu sens que pendant il
faut prendre ce moment là tu sens que
bon
[Musique]
il disait j'ai déjà assez assez réfléchi
en tout cas il était pas content il a
estimé avoir fait 300 tourradéen c'était
bizarre visuellement et c'est une petite
faute peut-être une de ses seules fautes
jusqu'à présent réel lors de ce niveau
alors
ben écoute je sais pas quoi parce qu'en
fait la menace des Noirs manger et de
faire caresser trop avec fourchettes sur
la tour et le fou maintenant la tour à
l'endroit il y a plus de fourchette avec
la tour de fou et on peut pas le faire
quand même sauf peut-être mais il a
peut-être là je peux bouger mon
voilà peut-être après cavalier prend B5
parce que maintenant ça va les fous de
couleur opposées
il y aurait eu mais même si c'était
quand même mais qu'avait déjà
intéressant
avec des idées de D4 contre jeu
je pousse le pion il y a la tour en
prise avec le fou et je peux essayer de
pousser le pion donc intéressant
c'est échanger un défaut contre le
cavalier pour en fait jouer avec un
meilleur fou que l'adversaire en fait et
par rapport aux échanges qui aurait pu
se faire avec cavaler qui peut manger là
et le cavalier qui peut manger ici et
bah les autres sont en défense par
rapport au foot des quatre et en tout
cas bon ok
j'ai l'impression
à deux ça ouais c'est vrai que ça nous
soulage énormément parce qu'on peut
installer deux tours en deuxième et le
coup à 5 sera vraiment difficile à jouer
quoi
H4
tranquille voilà
on active le roi
avec une minute de plus la minute 40
dépenser pour finalement rien du tout
parce que il a pas trouvé de
valorisation au contraire même il a
peut-être un peu dégradé
[Musique]
pour les Noirs d'espérer faire quelque
chose bon roi F6 sans doute et surtout
on peut pas jouer sur ces deux enfin un
peu mais il y a l'idéal 5 en fait sur ça
moi je m'en fous un peu
[Musique]
parce que sur ça
maintenant j'avais l'idée de 3 F2 parce
que si tu prends là je prends là et en
fait tu prends une tour je prends
l'autre et là j'entends le bébé
d'ammonium qui qui pleure
c'est pas des meilleures conditions pour
harmonial Hello
parce que là il est en train voilà
regardez hop égalisation et il veut
nulle maintenant il est d'accord
et voyez André Kim il veut jouer
maintenant
[Musique]
bon il trouve quand même un schéma de
nul c'est à dire qu'il va jouer le 3
contre 2
qui est nul mais avec 8 secondes c'est
chaud ce genre de position sous ça peut
toujours merdouiller non c'est pas trop
ou pas j'ai 4-5 on a envie de faire
aussi pour bloquer mais après il y a des
habits de partout
[Musique]
et
tu vois mettre le pion en F5 le orange
G4
passer par là ça fait un petit peu peur
mais bon ok je pense
gagner en tout cas voilà c'est une
chance
de la partie où il a été dominé il a
juste profité d'un bug d'aronium au
moment où il a passé une minute 40 bon
un bug ça nous arrive aussi hein on sait
bien salut Jacques
mais c'est le fameux coup on n'est pas
content après nous et puis ben direct
après on prend trop de temps
[Musique]
donc là il passe par là
tour des champions maintenant
prise plus les pions fait changer plus
j'ai une chance de faire du lin là bien
sûr je coupe le roi pour pas que le roi
vienne se mêler à la partie il faut
attendre je pense la tour où le roi
s'il monte le roi parce qu'on retrouve
en fait à chaque fois regardez c'est
malin ce qu'il fait
voilà on essaie F3 oulala oulala
[Musique]
côté
il a oublié le temps
de une une seconde à chaque coup mais si
jamais si simple de jouer vite comme ça
franchement il avait fait une partie
enfin il avait fait une partie et demi
complètement énorme où il marchait sur
l'eau à rognon il s'est complètement
éteint là dans dans cette dans cette
partie la réflexion d'une minute 40
horrible il y a pas le droit de dépenser
un tiers de son temps quasiment sur une
seule position et de faire ça derrière
quoi horrible en partie rapide vous
pouvez pas vraiment
bugger sur un seul coup il faut vraiment
essayer de jouer les coups et là c'est
vrai que la minute 40 qui la passe sur
le coup ça lui a fait vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de mal à
rognan et
et
en tout cas ok
pour l'intérêt du match quand même cool
que André Keane revienne
on est ravi surtout toi
mais
ok pour ceux qui n'était pas là qu'on a
parié avec sauve comme d'habitude nos
petits Seb et que à rognon c'est le
chouchou de stouf et j'en menais pas
large parce que j'ai vu les deux le deux
air arrivé là j'étais un petit peu
inquiet je voyais stouf sourire je me
suis dit non c'est pas vrai il va pas me
la coller encore et encore faut au moins
que je vibre un peu perdre oui mais y
croire un peu quoi mais je veux pas me
prendre la raclée le fameux 10-0 annoncé
par C4 tout à l'heure non ça j'en veux
pas du tout ça m'intéresse pas du tout
c'est pas le plan donc ce qu'on va voir
à rognan c'est un magicien ça m'a laissé
un rogner et moi je me souviens je passe
t'en souviens de cette fameuse
c'était des demi-finales de la Coupe du
monde contre un VL
en Armageddon qui avait été juste
exceptionnel franchement les joueurs ils
étaient franchement les deux joueurs
méritaient de se qualifier pour la
finale la Coupe du Monde
c'est le cas c'était mon avis à notre
chaîne cette année d'ailleurs rien que
le France entre entre Bacro et Moussa
c'est dans un autre registre mais là
encore pour le titre de champion quand
ça se départage en Armageddon pour des
gros matchs c'est dur pour celui qui
perd parce que ça veut dire que pendant
les parties lentes tous les Blitz sous
les rapides des fois on a fait jeu égal
et ça joue sur un coup de dé à la fin ça
peut être moche des fois
[Musique]
donc sans doute bêtement vu la jauge
mais gros avantage blanc avec le pionate
de plus et puis on ressent qui
paraissait potable si tu veux sauf mais
apparemment non
il a bien raison de vouloir jouer actif
par contre la partie est jolie avec le
roi conceptuel au centre le roi moderne
voyez on dit qu'il faut rocker
aux échecs maintenant en fait quand on a
appris à Rocket les joueurs très forts
qui maîtrisent le sujet ont appris à ne
pas croquer dans certains cas et là il a
gobé un pion et accepté qu'il de ne pas
croquer quoi et tourgé un c'est plus
sympa pour la colonne g le roi il est
derrière sa petite bande de pions
c'est pas facile de les désosser c'est
pion pourquoi pas
[Musique]
j'ai eu peur j'ai une bouteille d'eau
qui
vient de faire un petit peu
[Musique]
et elle est
ça m'a fait trop peur une bouteille
d'eau
comme ça alors
je sais pas elle reste un peu enfoncée
quoi enfin tu vois et en fait
elle s'est déplissée
elle a fait trop peur je comprends
le mime était très clair voilà
ok donc tour c'est lui qui a été joué en
fait là les noirs qui l'a rendu c'est un
peu étonnant moi j'aurais une fois que
tu as Gobel pion tu as envie de le
garder et non il l'a rendu en drakini il
a eu peur du jeu du jeu d'art rognan qui
fait encore une très jolie partie ma foi
mais après son plan c'est sûrement je
vais pousser trois cavaler des quatre
avec toi la paire de foutraquer quand
même sur le roi noir
oui et donc quand même ça en tout cas
son coup répond elle est clairement
justifiée parce que ça m'a l'air hyper
intéressant c'est compliqué à cette
position vous avez vu d'ailleurs qu'elle
pure H3 en l'air mais qui est très
difficile à gober à cause de tout rachat
par exemple être comme ça rien mais il y
a il y a vraiment du jeu de partout donc
difficile
à jouer mais ça me permet
comme ça il sera jamais en l'air bah
d'ailleurs sauf ta exaucé ouais donc là
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas partir
en fin il y a toujours froid donc c'est
quand même un peu énervant cette
histoire ouh là là
ou du D4 c'est ça l'idée mais oui
[Musique]
peut-être quand même parce que tu as pas
de Tours français 3 c'est très fort non
j'ai l'impression que tu reprends ces
trois ça a gagné sauf j'ai pas compris
pourquoi après
sur
forcer le roi à venir en deux après on
aurait eu un moment faut prendre des
cartes
d'ailleurs la jauge a buggé à ce moment
là ce qui a l'air de se comprendre après
les joueurs ils ont l'impression du
temps nous on est au commentaire koulos
[Musique]
je vois qu'il y a une pression
du coup
je pense pas
tu as compris bon
on peut le montrer
ce qui permet de manger le fout
tranquillement et si elle a la place à
miroir F1 et pas il y avait une fois je
crois échec et le roi de revenir ici
parce que c'est pas un coup et voilà
donc ce qui a été raté par les joueurs
et proposé par tout instantanément
on les met d'accord article par contre
là il se passe des trucs bizarres
ça a été joué
7 et à Rognac qui secoue la tête
encore de finir l'histoire non pas du
tout mais bon ça fait quand même
[Musique]
embêtant de se prendre ton projet 7
il faut prendre un chat derrière c'est
quoi
je regardais des choses comme ça je
n'arrivais pas à trouver un proche
c'est trop compliqué là il va de partout
l'ordinateur il donne nul il faut faire
pousser trois et chaque j'enlève déjà
les menaces en G7 et je vais bouffer ces
quatre
[Musique]
comme ça surtout reprend des 7 j'ai dame
Béa
franchement les joueurs trouvent des
ressources dans toutes les positions que
soient blanc noir c'est assez incroyable
quand même assez chaud
dans ma chatte nulle
ouais parce que je peux pas aller ici à
côté
chercher chercher mais
c'est monstre nul je pense il va prendre
le temps nul il y a pas de raison
là il y a vraiment déjà nul c'est un pas
un miracle mais c'était quand même chaud
ouais il était quand même très très mal
dans la position donc content et ça va
être la pub ça va être la pose les gars
donc je vous rappelle que à 45 minutes
et ben c'est la pub enfin c'est la pub
les gens dans une pause de 5 minutes
donc je ferai d'ailleurs même six
minutes exactement donc
c'était super chaud de toute façon donc
deux pour l'instant dans la voiture ça
va être beau ce match c'est un beau
match
donc les gars on va vous laisser cinq
petites minutes on fait un petit pages
de pub et on se retrouve directement
après
ne partez pas restez parmi nous hein on
revient pendant très très peu de temps
et donc hâte à tout de suite
allez bye bye à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour cette demi-finale qui commence à
l'instant avec harmonial avec les blancs
du coup c'est reparti donc 2
il y a eu une partie annulée
recommencer dans quelques instants donc
il y a pas filou non fil rouge je passe
tout noir malheureusement ici
[Musique]
vous le montrer à l'écran ici donc mvl
qui a battu nepo et Carola qui a battu
aussi erikasi vous voyez et on a aussi
Ding qui a battuk donc le vainqueur de
ce match là je vous raconte le vainqueur
de Nakamura par avion voilà on va
revenir sur la partie qui nous intéresse
quand même
à partir des cars voilà il y a déjà un
bel écrémage qui est fait c'est ça et
donc là on a la même partie tout à
l'heure je crois avec 5 qui a été le jeu
par an et Kin donc tout à l'heure il y a
eu cavalier prend
suivi de je sais plus ce qu'il avait les
jouets à trois il y avait une idée avec
avec des crans et un sacrifice de pièces
en E4
il avait joué F5 non il avait le
cavalier prend puis on prend et
ce qu'il avait joué et du coup c'est des
trucs est-ce que il a bossé de Mitry à
la
[Musique]
parce que s'il aille bossé serait pas il
serait pas en train de réfléchir une
minute maintenant
donc je sors qu'il a pas travaillé lui
donc que 5 qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici sur la 5
pas facile si tu prends cavalier prend
il y a le fou qui va être en prise et
perdre la part de fou aussi c'est pas
forcément
de malice comme ça tu vois il est
coutumier du fait je le trouve que dans
la base je le vois souvent pour des
idées qui sont assez peu joué mais en
pratique difficile quoi typiquement ça
ça doit pas être correct ce qu'il a fait
mais en fait c'est dur à réfuter on a vu
car rognan il avait du mal à réfuter
donc c'est que c'est que c'est
extrêmement compliqué
et contrôler aussi 5 en cas de prise
ou 2 EF4 c'est pénible déjà je vois bien
EF4 la Samsung logique y aller aussi de
la diagonale avec tous ces 5 choses
comme ça et pourquoi pas les deux
EF4 ça a l'air fort
c'est vraiment très sympa
[Musique]
et je prends 5
donc c'est pas simple de trouver un coup
pour pour le noir ici
[Musique]
mais le F4 ça me paraissait plus naturel
pour avoir les deux
qui vont
empêcher le rock
grand rock sur la cavalier F2 avec une
fourchette
ça marche parce que
ça pourrait être possible genre de truc
parce qu'il est quand même une annonce
développement blanche qui est quand même
assez assez grande mais il faut quand
même vérifier parce que c'est quelque
chose qui a été compliqué à calculer
c'était H3 tours F5 dans le même style
cavalier F2 tour F1 et c'est compliqué
c'est position là
puis on prend puis on prend et le fou
c'est 8 qui est coincé pour longtemps
peut-être et plus tarder de s'en sortir
le fou à de B5 C5 je sais pas
c'est pas foutu on l'a vraiment F4
j'aimais bien je suis un peu
il y va
[Musique]
inspirant de la position d'Android King
déjà parce que il y a des efforts à
faire
pas mal pour essayer en fait
[Musique]
je sais pas du tout si c'est bien ou pas
parce qu'on va dans la classe des cinq
mais d'un autre côté
[Musique]
et comme il a fait fout de classe
blanche il se disait que c'est lui qui
avait profité on va dire de ces cases
blanches mais au final
[Musique]
qui arrive
mais
top de suite c'est pas forcément l'idéal
ou là je peux dire ça par contre c'est
chaud
s
blanche des blancs il n'est pas là donc
du coup il peut se permettre de jouer FC
ici on peut jouer G4 aussi j'aime bien
G4 moi avec les Blancs
à l'ancienne une bretonne on appelle ça
dans le dans le jargon stuff
[Musique]
j'ai 4g5 j'aime beaucoup le fou en E7
qui vient et qui vient de s'échanger
contre le bon fou des deux et qui laisse
la place aussi
PAM Packard de prendre souffre je sais
pas si je te respecte
[Musique]
mais ok c'est quand même chaud parce que
faut avoir des coordonnées pour le
manger
[Musique]
sur la diagonale à vérifier maintenant
j'aime bien la position noire j'ai
l'impression qu'il a réussi à sortir des
troubles mais il y a des cases
de
sortir le foodcasme blanche avec un jour
faire C5
et en fait l'attaque très tendue entre
les deux joueurs ils s'en donnent à cœur
joie pour nous communiquer la tâche
je pense que tout n'est pas on voit
d'ailleurs au niveau de la jauge que ça
s'excite par moment parce que les
joueurs prennent des risques ou des
positions compliquées etc vous voyez pas
d'un coup la jauge qui s'excite
complètement mais quelle est la
justification
il y avait peut-être un problème
sur le pion des 4
en plus du pion où il a un gros problème
sur le son est compliqué James Bond bah
écoute jusque là je crois que ça
marchait plutôt pas mal
alors bah dites moi si le son est pas
bon ce qu'on peut essayer de remédier à
cela mais malheureusement nous on
s'entend pas donc on peut pas savoir
pas savoir
[Musique]
et Rogers
que moi moi je suis fort que lui
sans le faire mais
dites nous si il y a des choses qu'on
peut régler en tout cas parce que nous
on s'entend pas
j'ai de l'écho comment ça se passe
normalement j'en ai pas déco j'ai des
écouteurs
un peu déco chez toi apparemment bon moi
j'entends pas les cours Stéphane je te
le dis alors du coup je vais essayer de
baisser un petit peu mon micro
j'ai baissé un peu mon volume je sais
pas
tu as lancé tu as lancé les enchères là
et je pense je vous le dis que les
vannes va mater et de Mitry
il va se faire mater je pense dans cette
position
envoie tous les pièces qui vont dans le
même axe
là ça fait on a l'impression que tous
les coups marchent en plus
les bonnes vidéos à vérifier avec ses 40
secondes il y a un peu de pression tours
serré là sur le coup
comme ça il y a pas de pénétration faute
d'âme c'est deux des embrouilles et
après il va s'occuper de son cas de
l'autre côté
dans ces recoposé ce qu'il faut
comprendre alors normalement on dit
c'est la course à lattaque et après
quand ça devient un petit peu élaboré il
y a le côté gestion des coûts de frein
donc on met des coups de frein pour
contenir l'attaque adverse et ensuite on
envoie sur
sur l'adversaire directement on envoie
notre grosse attaque mais il y a un peu
de préparation donc 3G F3 bah maintenant
ok on a les mains libres pour faire
tourger ici
très très difficile à apparaître parce
qu'on a dame G7 et sur un coup comme
tour G8 je pense jouer cavalier G6 il va
jouer tourger
8 kg G6 les yeux fermés sauf
donc là il a fait G5 à cause de ça et
j'ai 6 et c'est foutu là c'est voilà
on a G7 et je prends un chat je prends
un chat ça fait mat
et le fou il est toujours horrible mais
et du coup c'est bizarre parce que la
dernière fois j'avais pas d'écho et j'ai
absolument rien changé
de meubler en fait ta pièce souffle
si tu voulais bien tu pourras peut-être
demander à une armoire chatcom avec un
truc bien
je vais être des meubles sur la pièce
maintenant quoi en plus
des tables et des armoires dans dans ta
pièce
est remplie donc
[Musique]
on aimerait bien un instant
voilà tu mets tout est trophées dans la
pièce bien joué route
je suis là mais j'ai déjà pas mal de
couple
je peux dire que ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas gagné une Coupe
pour moi
et
puis ouverture toute poussive avec les
Blancs là
pas de quoi
pas de quoi être hyper fier
très peu très peu franc-comtoir je joue
j'ai joué le Top 16 là en match par
équipe et c'est vraiment l'essentiel de
mon activité annuelle donc 10 parties
lents voir moins ouais c'est pas
beaucoup parce que bah voilà comme comme
stouf on est bien pris par
l'entraînement et tout ça et c'est donc
difficile de jouer j'aime bien jouer en
plus des gros tournois où je ne peux pas
gagner parce que le niveau est relevé
j'aime bien aller cogner des grands
maîtres et enfin surtout me faire cogner
du coup dans l'histoire mais en tout cas
je trouve ça beaucoup plus excitant que
de jouer des petits tournois pour des
primes je fais déjà l'entraînement aux
échecs donc quand je joue c'est vraiment
pour pour m'amuser donc j'aime bien
jouer des joueurs forts comme tout le
monde et aller faire des gros tournois
il faut quasiment une mobilité
européenne et avoir des dates qui est
coïncident en fait avec avec le tout
donc c'est pas c'est pas nécessairement
évident
malheureusement si j'aimerais bien
devenir amis mais sans jouer c'est pas
possible et en 2009 j'avais le même
niveau qu'aujourd'hui et si j'avais dû
faire ce choix là de passer GM il aurait
fallu que je me décide en 2010-2011 2012
à faire plein de tournois et ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que c'est
pas vraiment un métier à joueur d'échec
quand vous n'êtes pas 26 26 50 en tout
cas vous pouvez pas gagner votre vie
quoi c'est c'est le problème du truc
donc
et à l'époque c'était très différent
maintenant il y en a qui arrivent à
trouver des sponsors on voit que ça
commence à arriver mais c'était pas du
tout le cas il y a quelques années voilà
c'est complètement possible
en fait il aurait fallu que j'investisse
5 à 10 ans avec aucune certitude et du
coup bah
en étant au mieux au SMIC et encore au
mieux si vraiment donné pas de secours
Stéphane ça la vie ne serait pas la même
quoi donc
tirer à la bourre avec stouffe pour pour
gagner gagner des petits prix dans les
petits tournois ça serait une autre vie
il y en a qui en font ça on a toujours
vu un des joueurs particulièrement des
nations des pays de l'Est galéré en tant
que joueur pro aux échecs avec des
niveaux sensiblement comme le nôtre de
23,50 à 2450 et voir plus 25-2550 parce
que il faut les garder après quand vous
faites des tournois ou vous enchaînez
des semaines et des semaines à jouer aux
échecs c'est extrêmement dur vous avez
pas le même niveau que si vous êtes
frais comme un gardon hyper motivé pour
jouer aux échecs des fois vous enchaînez
vous finissez un tournoi le matin vous
enchaînez l'après mais avoir fait là
après avoir fait la route
les cours ça nous rémunirait bien oui
tout à fait et le fait de faire du
streaming ça doit apporter une notoriété
pour attirer des sponsors après tout
dépend du stream peut-être que tout feu
il a une notoriété incroyable en tout
cas moi ça reste limité quand même dans
la rue pour l'instant on n'arrête pas
sauf je sais pas si toi tu arrêtes dans
la rue mais
moi j'habite au canari donc c'est encore
encore plus difficile
ouais je me rendais pas compte de la
portée de ce qu'on faisait sur sur
internet mais on le voit avec les
chaînes YouTube et effectivement ça
apporte un peu mais pour l'instant ça
reste des chaînes qui sont assez
confidentiels qui sont pas grand public
donc attirer les sponsors dans ces
cas-là c'est compliqué ça voudrait dire
un changement de vie aussi
route maintenant j'ai pas le même âge
j'ai une fille conjointe et aller jouer
les tournois bah c'est des semaines
d'absence qui sont ballantage avec les
vacances familiales donc si vous voulez
passer grand maître il faut le faire le
plus tôt possible
ou alors vous allouez vraiment tout
votre temps à cela mais c'est trop tard
normalement mais il y a une certaine
logique c'est qu'on n'était pas assez
fort avec stouf jeune on était fort sans
être assez fort pour prétendre dans
vivre mais on le voit avec d'autres
joueurs Sébastien Mazet Mathieu cornette
qui sont des joueurs exceptionnels et
qui n'en vivent même pas en tant que
joueur c'est à dire que il donne des
cours pour pour en vivre ou ils font des
activités autres ou du le fait d'être
sans Gourdon mais c'est rare que l'on
puisse être joueur exclusive quoi voilà
c'est réservé à l'élite de l'élite
Étienne Bacro Laurent Freyssinet Maxime
va chez Lagrave aller résa firuja et
encore que Étienne et Laurent qui sont
extrêmement forts là on parle de l'élite
de l'élite
ben au fur et à mesure qu'ils avancent
en âge bah ils font moins quand même de
tournois ils ont aussi eux leurs revenus
annexes
d'aller jouer les tournois les enchaîner
et tout ça
bon on va revenir au jeu quand même
il se passe pas grand chose dans cette
variante alors ils nous ont joué la
vente la plus jouée à haut niveau pour
faire nul quand même faut le savoir et
c'est assez étonnant qu'on joue ça avec
les Blancs parce que il est mené comme
score
et donc c'est assez étonnant l'espace
pas grand chose c'est assez égal les
pièces
[Musique]
qui peut gagner à vague n'importe quelle
ouverture quand ça se tend et puis il a
pas trop envie de montrer peut-être des
petits lignes sympas dans ce genre de
deux tournois hyper rapide il veut
garder ses petites prépas pour plus tard
il est mené et puis mais stop quoi mais
ça
c'est terrible c'est terrible
le jeu solide
parce que les noirs
[Musique]
sont un peu moins bien voilà
on prend aussi c'est un peu tout match
je pense
c'est cher l'idée c'est un jour de
l'idée
sympa mais d'ailleurs les vans c'est pas
fait prier pour jouer très rapidement
le petit tour B7 qui contrôle la
septième rangée bon il y a un petit plus
alors
on peut travailler longtemps
donc avoir
dans ma 6 ok je contrôle un peu la pose
tame 2 peut être un coup un jour pour
s'activer
c'est logique je trouve et maintenant on
va essayer d'envoyer le pion a un moment
c'est stable on peut peut-être faire
tourner trois tourgers 3 aussi sauf pour
trouver un petit thème
va tourner trois tours j'ai trois je
pense qu'il le préparait avec ça
d'ailleurs c'était le principe des 2e
faiblesse
[Musique]
systématiquement
des trois quand même il a préféré
tourser un pensez qu'il a joué le tour
des trois avec une petite un petit
pressing
c'est pas très logique mais
généralement c'est pas facile de jouer
des cours rapidement à cette cadence
dans cette position donc
la rivonne il avance il a aussi la
pression même si il joue très bien c'est
pas lourd
c'est malin ce coup-là
il va revenir peut-être en Descartes
pour
pour garder le pressing
il a préféré il a préféré changer
d'accord et comment je fais parce que
j'aurais peur du piond peut-être F3 tout
simplement
et ouais voilà et on va chercher le pion
ah il a joué à H4 d'accord
[Musique]
la différence étroit je pense ça mange
pas de temps tourner un tour des deux
évidemment ah oui voilà nul maintenant
ça c'est plus facile à faire de faire
mieux
prise pour B6 et ça va se liquider les
tourbières juste je pense que tout là
toi aussi peut-être qui est coupé le roi
et dès que la tour
[Musique]
celle-là j'ai l'impression que c'est
quand même c'est compliqué la vie non
ouais bon
parce que là j'ai un peu passé
maintenant
mon roi blanc est coupé en plus donc
il y avait G5 par exemple qui était
tranquille
il chauffe pour tout à l'heure
c'est pas un peintre
[Musique]
pour tout le respect que j'ai pour les
peintres
mais bon ce qui va réussir à faire
quelque chose dans cette position j'y
crois pas
tomber quoi
on a bien parlé du coup on a bien parlé
dans cette
partie la plus chiante depuis le début
on va pas se mentir sauf
là on a senti en fait elle était assez
représentative de l'ouverture choisie
par par André King
et du coup à ces décevant parce qu'on
avait vu des parties de folie là ce soir
et là c'est là pour c'était c'était pas
drôle ok une Espagnole
tu sais salut
patate j'ai un truc pour toi
c'est un truc pour toi
surveille le discord tout à l'heure à la
pause je mettrai un truc pour toi
[Musique]
dans un bar et puis il y avait des jeux
de société et jouer à un jeu de
questions ou tu sais quoi de blague il y
avait une carte avec une blague dessus
et voilà quand je l'ai vu j'ai pensé à
toi directement j'ai dit que que de
l'envoyer et c'est quoi le jeu souffle
est-ce qu'on peut avoir le nom du jeu
c'est un jeu il y a des blagues dessus
et je sais plus bon
mais c'est pas un jeu génial mais
jusqu'à la carte est géniale par rapport
à un truc qu'on avait dit dans stream
une fois
c'est vraiment une preuve joker
à ton avis
[Musique]
quand est-ce que je me suis dit
sur toi
à quel sujet
le métal
[Musique]
donc là les gars c'est une ligne de
l'Espagnol qui est qui est vraiment très
très solide et il se passe pas grand
chose pour l'instant dans le mur de
Berlin on peut le dire donc vous voyez
après
l'écossaise variant hyper pénible ou le
4 cavaliers écossais qu'on vient de
vivre on a le droit la berlinoise donc
là on rétine je sais pas pourquoi il
s'est mis en mode solide il a peut-être
envie de régler son compte à aller van
en
hyperbulette tout à l'heure après ça va
être solide mais bon c'est pas si simple
les dons ont la paire de fou contre une
depuis que j'ai dit qu'il était plutôt
créa il commence à jouer hyper plat tu
vois
on va passer
[Musique]
de bonnes prochaines heures si vous
changez de place forme là
il faut qu'on joue un petit peu des
trucs couverts pour nous exciter un
petit peu
les échanges de pièces
pas rigolo là
ça a l'air logique on va voir
essayer de reprendre de la tour on peut
jouer fouger 5 rois 7
une fois
si les joueurs font un mix
ah bah c'est pareil
[Musique]
Frankois
les règles sont les mêmes pour les deux
joueurs
on peut pas réclamer en disant j'ai pas
fait exprès
c'est un peu comme quand tu touches une
pièce tu as pas fait exprès bah tu l'as
dans la main pour la bouger quand même
après
qu'est-ce que tu as dans la main bon
[Musique]
sans doute pour revenir comme le délai
habituel et puis voilà si tu es pas dans
le délai
[Musique]
ils vont être un peu bloqués pour ce
match par contre
c'est le seul le seul truc
[Musique]
il leur a dit dernière avertissement en
deux ou pas
[Musique]
et
quand même pas c'est simple pour le noir
parce que la tour elle est un peu
passive je vois pas trop trop de choses
à faire pour le noir
après celui qui a choisi de rentrer
là-dedans parce qu'il était vraiment il
avait des simplifications pour bon après
là il prend l'espace à l'aile dame donc
avec les Blancs faut aussi savoir
comment on valorise cette position
est-ce que c'est un coup d'ourage 5 avec
l'idée que
je peux revenir avec un tour ici G4
[Musique]
non mais en fait peut-être que ça en
plus il y a tout reprend G5 souffle
et quand je vais 5 cavaliers H4
et bravo stuff tu sais ceci oh c'est
chaud j'avais pas vu tu sais j'ai vu
après
qui va peut-être gagner la partie grâce
à ce coup énorme
et s'il fait B4 il a fixé sur la
mauvaise couleur
des faibles tout simplement très jolie
structures un peu bien sûr
après on triplé des fois c'est pas si
grave parce que tu peux quand même avoir
du jeu mais pas un plat après prise
torsades si je pouvais avoir pour bébé
directement ça serait quand même pas
clair oui mais ici c'est vrai que
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle franchement
il joue à 6 c'est peut-être mais non
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut jouer à 4
juste pour les montrer en fait que
ça serait rigolo
genre tour des trois ici avec l'idée
tour à trois par exemple ça pas mal
aussi j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
ils sont là les Noirs ont 4 pions entre
3 et en fait grâce à mon C4 et ben les
Noirs ont jamais vraiment une majorité
quoi parce que le processus
donc là il y a eu qu'un voyage
ou quand même parce que tous les pièces
maintenant commencent à être bizarre
chez les noirs
on comprend ni les pions ni les pièces
alors est-ce que ça va suffire pour
gagner des fois ça reste solide chez les
Noirs mais il souffre quand même un donc
là il y a eu cavalier
F4 G5 c'est vraiment qu'on va faire
je suis pas sûr
mais j'ai l'impression je sais pas si
c'est un rognant qui joue plus lendemain
ou André King qui joue plus vite mais
par contre au niveau du temps
j'ai l'impression qu'il est un peu plus
lent quand même mais ça compte beaucoup
à cette cadence là
que c'est bien de peaufiner son jeu mais
quand ça finit en grande importe quoi à
la fin
on a vu les vannes qui avaient une très
très bonne position tout à l'heure qui a
du défendre ça ça très bonne position à
la fin qui s'était complètement gâté
donc faut faire vraiment attention à la
gestion du temps dans ces cadence ultra
courtes c'est pas facile parce qu'il y a
des temps creux et il a suffi que j'en
parle pour que André Kim fasse peut-être
une des plus longues réflexions de
de la partie alors les tensions juste
parce que
les temps sont vus
C1 qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu roi des 7
est-on contre juste ouf que tu avais
annoncé pour B8 tour B5 voilà tomber
vite fait
et du coup tu as plus contre je vraiment
B3 on a l'impression qu'on va se faire
complètement
trois faiblesses
il suffit que j'arrive à passer un petit
F4 à un moment pour soutenir le pion
donc je sais pas peut-être fou des deux
fou c'est 3 fois 4
bien joué
[Musique]
ouais le problème c'est que j'avais mon
mon Pione 5 à surveiller donc il va
mettre tout ça en place et là en drykin
il doit s'apercevoir qu'il est
complètement foutu
une pression blanche sur cette position
et même 30 secondes contre une minute il
va falloir vraiment que
même au temps c'est quand même pas mal
mais bon
et Beckham d'embrouille pour changer
toute la position
et attention que
il y a la
fourcheiner à rognan
c'est incroyable à ce niveau là ça
arrive encore une fois tous ces cinq
bien joué sans doute plus facile
vous voyez à rognon il avait il a pour
l'instant il a bien mieux joué que on
doit écrire vraiment rien à voir
et il se retrouve à
à jouer cette position désespérée bon
comme il a 10 secondes on va attendre
quand même la fin mais honnêtement que
j'ai 4 cavaliers 5 terminé voilà tout de
suite perdu
donc il est dingue parce qu'il a bien
fait à André Kid là il a fait un petit
soupir hyper moche pour l'instant les
deux joueurs sont égalité et pourtant il
y avait une classe d'écart ce soir
jusqu'à présent entre les vannes à
rognan et André Kin
ouais on s'acheminait quand même vers
une victoire assez tranquille de Levon à
rognan tout fait et du coup tout est
lancé
souffre il est vrai que avec un petit
sourire dans la voix que je te dis ça
c'est ouf
2 avant
la peut-être la dernière partie du 17
on a parié sur sur chacun des joueurs
avec bon bah et sur chaque 7 sur
résultat final etc et puis au final pas
très content de voir attraper dans cette
partie
je vous conseille à la partie qui a eu
lieu c'est une des belles préparations
qui existent dans cette ligne des quatre
cavaliers écossais là
c'est toute une ligne forcée c'est une
partie assez
assez connu entre nepo et karwana si je
dis pas de bêtises et voilà c'est une
autre façon de jouer cette variante là
c'est archi plat
donc du coup bonne chance de nul déjà on
peut vous le dire normalement cette
position c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
soporifique est-ce que le but de
cette position qui bougent pas
en tout cas c'est possible
je sais pas
alors créatif c'est un joueur qui qui
aime bien quand ça bouge qui a toujours
plein d'idées c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai en tout cas là il était en
train de bien normalement il est il
était à +2 quoi et là maintenant il se
retrouve à égalité mais sur une sur une
énorme connerie dans notre position
archi avantageuse encore une fourchette
en deux coups
de faire ça alors imag
[Musique]
voilà on s'ennuie vous voyez les
échanges qui arrivent et bon ok on a un
fond intéressant mais on aime bien le
Claval aussi
[Musique]
tu vois pour essayer de rester
mais effectivement il doit faire les
efforts maintenant Dame des trois dame
B3
non mais là honnêtement
[Musique]
pour ces cinq
c'est fou parce qu'il joue pas il joue
vraiment là le coup prend F6 c'était tu
vois si j'avais eu un élève qui joue au
foot je dis bah c'est pas bon tu as ton
fou
hyperactifs du monde quoi qui le joue
d'accord
plus compréhensible si vous voulez mais
là une fois de stratégique de ce
niveau-là vous avez un fou comme qui est
hyper fort
[Musique]
et en plus ça laisse passer les tours en
H8 comme à distance donc c'est encore
plus de plus de problèmes quoi on voit
qu'il devient actif
qui devient vraiment réalisable le pion
qui est qui est donné ici
donc
au pire je te regarde qui est toujours
possible
ouais
[Musique]
c'est en train de s'équilibrer quand
même au final c'est pas important
il va y avoir l'âme C7 et simplification
[Musique]
chaque fois
je me suis dit bon ça devrait quand même
ça fait nul direct ok bon
en tout cas soporifique cette partie
complètement il nous reste un
dernier dernière shot un dernier shot
pour gagner donc
un petit peu il joue une à lapine
[Musique]
du coup D4 a été joué donc là en partant
de cavalier donc avaler c'est 6 voilà
donc sous les 5 cavaliers
aussi on le sait dans ses positions
différents donc la cavalue S7 qui
empêche du coup romain avec chaque on
très souvent les blancs font finir par
mangeant ces sac ici pour en fait
voilà créer du coup le pion isolé et
arrivé avec le cavalier en métro et
peut-être ou un fou ou trois pour
bloquer un petit peu ce pion
ce pion isolé en dessin
en tout cas oui ça paraît
ça parait assez étonnant alors qu'on
avait assisté à un début de match en
fanfare c'était hyper joli et là ça
c'est vraiment assez petit les parties
bon c'est d'ailleurs de la faute
d'Android King il a failli le payer cher
d'ailleurs mais
à rognan lui a rendu la politesse avec
une grosse fourchette bien dégueu
bon et là peut-être c'est un peu moins
bien que d'habitude pour arrogant parce
que tu sais il y a fou c'est tous les
tous les conneries dame G3 ouh là là
[Musique]
c'est hyper chaud
mais attention que l'attaque peut aussi
à la cave de Kevin bug ouais excusez-moi
je sais pas ce que je vais la foutu avec
le je crois que voilà c'est ça c'est bon
on voit Kevin je suis désolé j'avais la
petite bague je suis toujours là ouais
j'avais vu ta caméra enfin j'avais bougé
le discord
merci
je savais pas que c'était faute de jeu
aussi ouais ouais je j'ai vécu ça un
moment
mais oui hyper chaud en tout cas ça va
coûter du temps en drykin mais en fait
ces colonnes qui s'ouvrent sur le roi
blanc
quand même
[Musique]
trois menaces non
cavalier 5 peut-être ça fait les deux
[Musique]
aussi dans cette position peut-être
pas une menace parce qu'en fait j'ai
cavalais prendre
FH fait reprendre F2 et le cavalier est
un
il faut être précis la vague est noir en
tout cas s'est mis je pense qu'à rognon
n'avait pas été très précis dans le
début mais il s'est fourré dans un truc
c'est André King qui se retrouve un peu
[Musique]
pas content du tout mais très très
bientôt tu verras c'est c'est parti
commenter par mes soins sur Youtube
oh là là il y a du lourd du lourd qui
arrive très très lourd qui arrive
le combat
tirant
qui perd quatre points et l'eau alors ça
vous gagne
donc tour 8 et c'est pas la bonne
solution parce que maintenant on doit
pouvoir éteindre l'incendie avec d'un
meuf 3 ou dame G4 un des deux
donc sa force vraiment l'échange voilà
d'être plus précis une surprise
cavaliers 2 et c'est la même problème en
cavalier franchement
cool non c'est Baptiste enfin cool pour
la vidéo Youtube
il pensait je pense que c'est Baptiste à
la vidéo Youtube je pense qu'il parle de
ça il n'a pas pensé
mais normalement c'est super bien
en tout cas donc
[Musique]
en difficulté dans cette dans cette
partie va essayer de bricoler un truc il
existe
en E3 avec cavaler prendre le bouge ma
tour et ben au final chacun pour la
pièce puis une minute une minute contre
4 autant dire que maintenant bon là
rognan il reste 37 secondes dans ce
cette fin de 7
deg le bon coup peut-être
il fait tout ce qui peut
à rognon pour laisser en drykin
tranquille
il est quand même
pas sur un dans ce qui fait hein
on a connu plus impressionnant après il
reste du temps on a vu la dernière fois
j'étais hyper serein après la pause
d'une heure et demie
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a ici
4-0 tu sais après la pause du 5 + 1 donc
on va pas faire trop les malins là
[Musique]
retournement un énième
il se prend le sacrifice ils sont H3 la
totale la plus le choix punaise je pèse
tout c'est pas possible quoi
largement c'est pour ça que je suis
dégoûté qu'il fasse ça sur la dernière
parce que je me dis déjà c'est
incroyable qu'il soit en vie
et là il joue pas à son niveau habituel
André King
il reste plus qu'une 20 secondes à la
pendule avec les Noirs faut pas qu'il se
précipite quand même harmoniaque
tranquille
garder les pièces ou F5
je me ferai en fait mais
tu sais le drame non ça part pas de
toute façon
alors ça prépare éventuellement l'idée
avec un psychiatre
il faut juste jouer simple et je solide
il y a beaucoup de temps à la pendule il
faut juste
garder les pions avec les avec les avec
les Blancs quand même pas trop échange
des pions quoi alors c'est quand même
par exemple
[Musique]
en plus pour pour Dimitri en i-fin ouais
là vraiment partir à thé
c'est fou de voir ça
il est parti de folie et là dans la
preuve après la première pause ça casse
les joueurs un peu les pauses parce que
on l'a vu ça dans le match car wanna
contre
[Musique]
à chaque pause ça a changé le rythme
exactement bien d'accord avec toi sauf
c'est pas un coup parce que du coup les
noirs doivent regarder les pièces
cavalides
moi il me fait peur
j'aimerais bien que le beau jeu jusqu'au
bout voilà allez le beau jeu le beau jeu
le beau jeu
heureusement
chez pour le bon jeu jusqu'au bout ah là
là matin il va y avoir
5 ça sent le matelas
il doit chercher le maths
et ça va être la fin
la fin de ce premier jour
il venait de passer complètement à côté
stuff et du coup
[Musique]
on a un joueur préféré on préférait tous
les deux à rognan parce que
c'est à rognon c'est la légende par
rapport à driking quand même je dirais
André King c'est un joueur de renom et
mais à rognon c'était une super star
d'autant plus qu'il y a un historique
quand même c'est à rognan c'était le
joueur qui
concurrent d'Étienne macro quand il
était plus jeune donc voilà on a suivi
les les carrières un petit peu et à
rognon à percer au plus haut niveau et
c'est maintenu à ce très très haut
niveau quoi avec des préparations de
folie c'était énorme donc énorme joueur
pour moi
mais malheureusement j'ai choisi en
dream
et du coup bah il va falloir que je m'en
remette je trouve parce que c'est mal
parti quoi c'est mal parti
en pause je vais essayer de me poser ma
pièce
tout ce que j'ai
si vous savez pas quoi faire pendant
pendant les pauses vous pouvez aller sur
nos chaînes respectives à la chaîne de
stouf
et du même nom et la chaîne prévolution
échec ça nous fera un plaisir de de vous
retrouver donc n'hésitez pas vraiment
quand vous savez pas quoi faire quand on
est en pause vous êtes triste des fois
alors que vous allez voir des des
centaines et des milliers d'informations
sur notre site respectifs et moi je peux
pas vous mettre le lien de ma chaîne
parce que je suis modo je peux pas moto
moto faire la pub mais aller
sur ma chaîne c'est tout donc si vous
voulez voir twitch vous pouvez trouver
quand même quasiment tous les jours donc
n'hésitez pas à passer en tout cas ce
qu'on obtient de vous de voir
et du coup on va un petit pause et on se
on se revoit ici ben 4 minutes voilà
donc restez parmi nous ne partez pas et
à tout de suite pour la suite de ce
dénouement qui sera plus une et pendant
une heure à tout de suite à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui va arriver dans quelques instants
les gars Kevin qui arrive à peine
j'ai entendu l'arbitre qui a annoncé que
ça a commencé du coup je me suis permis
de revenir avant toi
donc du coup on a 5 4 dans ce premier
set qui était de 5 plus une
d'aborder changer
le rythme là on va on va passer une
maintenant
donc
pendant une heure il y aura une pause au
milieu ou d'une demi-heure et donc
premier set du coup pour
un rognan 5 4 on va commencer maintenant
en vrai c'était chaud c'était chaud il y
a eu des parties un petit peu bizarre
mais un royal qui a pris le dessus alors
est-ce que le sujet
bien bien au dessus
André Kin quand même en grande
difficulté et normalement il devrait
être à plus trois rognon en vue des
matchs bon il se retrouve à plus un donc
tout reste à faire et on driking va
sûrement se réveiller je vais trouver
les parties étaient super sympa au début
je trouve que ça s'est dégradé le niveau
de jeu particulièrement Dream juste
merci c'est pour cette pub
avec parce que moi je peux pas moto
taguer et donc merci
à toi donc oui il
[Musique]
a oui qui double les blancs
en 3 + 1 et on voit qu'en Dream qui
change qui joue à un système Ready avec
les blancs avec cavalier F3
alors pour le son est-ce que ça va mieux
ou pas parce que j'ai rajouté des trucs
j'ai pris j'ai pris le fauteuil du chat
c'est pas impossible que ce soit mieux
[Musique]
une petite caisse de résonance et du
coup il y a moins
je rajoute des trucs dans la
pièce s'il vous plaît si le son
de meilleure qualité si pendant la
prochaine pause
[Musique]
je t'ai envoyé
ça allait ok après
alors est-ce que je peux manger
il va prendre de la tour en C6 sans
doute donc on attend un petit peu il y
avait aussi le
voilà c'est ça exactement
[Musique]
ce qu'ils font
on y a
c'est mieux ok nickel ok du coup
tu as trouvé tu as trouvé la technique
je sais pas comment tu as fait j'ai pris
le meuble
un petit fauteuil c'est le fauteuil du
chat avec sa couverture et on va parler
[Musique]
exactement
j'ai mis ça ici j'ai mis des couvertures
je veux pas la fenêtre
il avait une heure trente dans le
premier 7 maintenant ils ont une heure
dans le deuxième avec un
raccourcissement de la cadence qui met
en trois plus une et ensuite pour la
dernière cadence ça sera du 3e en Bullet
pour la Dana tendance
alors C5 qui est tout à fait normal
l'idée c'est de venir casser un peu tout
ça j'aime beaucoup les blancs cette
position je sais pas ce que tu en penses
ouais très clairement c'est les blancs
qui ont la pression en fait ici sur sur
les Noirs ils vont la mettre jusqu'au
bout je pense à deux normalement qui en
censé être draguer braquer dans la
Catalane sur la dame là malheureusement
les Noirs ont réussi à quand même le
gérer il y a plus d'espace en fait
finalement on comprend pourquoi la jauge
est à l'équilibre
on a deux gros cavaliers mais en fait
ils les auront aussi les cavaliers
sympas
[Musique]
peut-être manger en dessin
j'aime pas trop donner la carte de fou
mais
bon ce qu'on va faire minimaliste comme
avantage mais bon
il a en fait il a obtenu que ça entre
guillemets c'est à dire que il a pas
réussi à avoir mieux parce que ton prix
parce que
donc là on espère un cavalier C4
peut-être mais peut-être juste torse 5
courage on va pas vraiment l'avantage
des blancs ici en cette position
très solide par contre
une minute de moi pas qui s'endorme
C5 m'a l'air ok c'est échanger les
pièces donc on se prend
à voir si ça perd pas à quelque chose
j'ai un peu peur que c'est des fois
même là même si on venait à perdre un
pion et le seul risque pour la Réunion
c'est qu'il est sous pression du temps
et du coup de faire une bêtise
il a été un petit peu lent peut-être au
passage de cadence
mais sinon je trouve qu'il fait une
partie de défense intéressante avec les
Noirs quand même
[Musique]
il a muselait le fouger d'eux c'est ce
qu'on lui demandait et du coup
pas trop se créer de faiblesse Chris
coup franc
et avoir un peu comment comment on
termine la pause
ok
on peut tenter de
[Musique]
passer de faire des cadets
mais bon histoire ça a l'air quand même
plutôt égal peut-être voilà pour créer
l'histoire faut prendre cavalier
cavaliers F6 et maintenant on aura un 4
contre 3 à jouer
sans doute nul cette position mais un
peu galère avec les 14 secondes
restantes donc là on peut mettre la
pression met le roi en E4 et on voit
il y aura quand même des fourchettes
voilà
pour 5 toujours là à 4 on peut jouer
préférais carte nettement mais bon
c'est bizarre
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut le faire quand tu
rêves 5 et après on rebouche le roi
F4 ou F3
il veut créer un blocus sur 15 ans
peut-être
mais le cavalier je crois pas trop
intéressant
[Musique]
il va faire tourner avec son carvalier
il joue vite franchement à Rennes
il a perdu une partie autant tout à
l'heure
il est bien dans le match 3 va être joué
ouais
de loin voilà
il est un petit peu
je crois très tendu
et j'ai deux en attendant
pas tomber là pas tomber
pas tomber parce que il faut le retenir
le cahier des trois terminé je pense
avec E5
on prend
il va essayer de faire aussi un joueur
est perdu il faut le laisser
en tout cas malgré tout il y aura une
grosse défense de d'arrognant cette
partie et là la durer plusieurs fois
il faut attendre là
ça peut se liquider dès que le pions
je pense ça
gagnant mais il a raté un petit peu je
pense
pour réussir à jouer dans la bonne
circonstance il a du mal à bouger le
qui empêche de
se faire
qui pourrait le choper le fou il va
essayer de choper le four
[Musique]
parce qu'on reste un petit peu au milieu
pour les deux joueurs les rois 8
joueurs de 2 côtés pas le droit
attention
incroyable comme défense oh là là il a
raté
et franchement grosse grosse défense
la terre
en tout cas c'est bon là c'était c'était
mieux que certains
duels et il a pas été très convaincu je
pense André King tout à l'heure par le
traitement d'arrognan il relève le pur
H3
c'est marrant tu vois il a répété
très sympa petite passe d'armes
les deux joueurs il y a Levana rognan
qui nargue un peu en Dream dans cette
variante stouf
ça fait deux fois que c'est un peu
bizarre ce qui fait
Harmonia on n'a pas trop envie d'y
croire il a laissé encore une fois le
plan en plus de quoi tu vois
la cavalier F5 sans doute c'était pas
très bon
il aurait presque déménagé si je pense
tout pour laisser les fous proches 3
laisser les cavaliers car laisser les
cavaliers H4
et il s'est un peu laissé
maintenant ils vont répéter peut-être
encore ça
[Musique]
j'aime pas donner mon foot 15 ans quand
même c'est bizarre non
là il y a quand même la paire de Foucher
les noirs avec une pression sur
sur ici
[Musique]
en fait
de voir ce qui se passe
mineur mais bon quand même les pièces
restantes des Noirs sont très actives
[Musique]
qui peut arriver donc le but c'est aussi
de faire ça ça et peut-être mais chaque
donc un peu se passer mais vous voyez
que dès que le cavalier par dès qu'il
saute d'un match de et c'est très très
chaud
qu'est-ce qu'on a vraiment envie de de
se prendre un match de ouf j'ai trois
avec les jouets du coup il règle ça
comme ça et du coup il ouvre les casse
pas en chanson
c'est toujours un peu énervant
mesdames c'est clair qu'on va taper sur
avec une place de dames
est-ce que c'est que ça oui avec le dé
qui avalé prend 4
comme ça
même les noirs
préférés
juste normal en fait c'est bloquer un
petit peu ce pion à splendide parce que
je dois aussi des idées éventuellement
un jour avec des cartes que c'est pour
ouvrir un case blanche tout à fait
[Musique]
3 font d'éclatent mais alors quand même
très
bon là en tout cas on voit que c'est
plus speed maintenant on voit on doit
écrire il met la pression on est en 3
minutes chacun c'est un peu étonnant
d'avoir laissé le souvenir en 4 je
trouve le dernier coup d'arrognan qui a
et B3 il va peut-être se raviser à cad2
un moment donc on me demande
le micro alors depuis le début du stream
je sais pas ce qui se passe pour micro
généralement mon son est très bon donc
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe
donc
le fait d'être plusieurs tout ça c'est
compliqué
menace 3 donc est-ce qu'il va rejouer
qu'il y a des deux ça ressemble assez
logique j'ai fait un truc est-ce que ça
va mieux
[Musique]
préférer parce que ça va pas bien F5 F4
est-ce que c'est jouable F5 F4 là
[Musique]
là ça risque d'être long quand même pour
les voies d'arrognants
je suis désolé pour le son maintenant
c'est bien qui est que 50 secondes
chaque
c'est cool qu'ils aient plus gros de
temps parce que la pollution est très
mauvaise donc du coup peut-être un peu
de temps pour la finir donc là on drague
King commence à ramener du monde à la
fête discretos qui est des quatre du
coup voilà très discret maintenant j'ai
cinq peut-être souffre
je suis pas sûr que ce soit quand même
bon pour les pour les pour les Noirs
4G 2 est-ce que tu as gagné quelque
chose après
ouais c'est ça donc c'était intéressant
quand même mais bon il fallait
accepter de donner ce fou magnifique
parce que c'est j'essaie de faire des
choses
excuse-toi oui est-ce que c'était
ton coup incroyable regarde
qui va être quasiment maths le tour à
charge encore fougerant c'est pas du
tout match c'est une grosse un gros
blender sans doute vu la jauge
et il a fait le G5 que je proposais en
Dream mais de façon
c'est mieux
il a cru que c'était maths en fait vous
voyez on peut avoir des allures quand on
est sous pression du temps maman drykin
qui est très à l'aise dans ce registre
il a cru qu'il matait
[Musique]
5 il va peut-être raser
qui peut arriver moi c'est très très bon
[Musique]
aussi les deux joueurs sont avec la
tourage ce qui me lassait et aurait-kim
qui perd autant
c'est un grosse partie en tout cas
encore une fois de des joueurs
monstrueux franchement
là il y a eu juste là c'est un peu
l'effet inverse de ce qui s'est passé
tout à l'heure en Drake il avait été
dominant et malheureusement il lâche au
dernier moment
en croyant faire maths
des quasiment des machines de guerre les
mecs ils peuvent quand même sur un coup
tout [ __ ] en l'air c'est ce qu'on a vu
avec Android
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux couper le son du zoom
mais c'est peut-être ça en fait qui fait
défaut
mais j'ai le son du zoom
sur
l'arbitre parle tout ça
il y a pas un prise cette position
[Musique]
c'est très très joli
extrêmement esthétique ce qui vient de
se passer André Kim qui vient de faire
une belle dose dans la position d'avant
il a pas peur
[Musique]
ici tout en même temps
mais
on verra
il doit avoir tout ça mais c'est dur de
se décider là
la fin du 5 + 1 vous l'avez vécu à
Haguenau c'était c'était un peu lourd et
là c'est reparti sur des parties
vraiment hyper créa sympa là ce qu'on
voit c'est le beau jeu quoi clairement
à la fin donc moi je vois un petit fouet
3 mais aussi
le four revient et là et comment on fait
là
bah là maintenant on voit que
c'est payant grosse partie dans le Reiki
là pour pour démarrer rapide efficace
contre les cases du cavalier quand il
sort mais bon ok je serai fou 4
c'est sans doute la bonne ligne pour
essayer de d'embrouiller
mais ces trois
[Musique]
chasser manger donc il faut mettre la
tour F pour éviter tout Rasset je crois
sauf
[Musique]
il y a deux écoles
mais
à rognan a trouvé quand même des choses
assez folles ici voilà c'est beau jeu
rousse je suis d'accord
comme le coup
à 4 et le cavalier il a pas trop de
cases
et c'est un tour c'est un fou B2
attention
il a pas joué
nous en nous font un mentir à chaque
fois que parement j'ai l'impression
qu'on se comprend mais que eux ils se
comprennent aussi
nous on se comprend
mais par contre on les comprend pas eux
ils sont beaucoup trop fort pour nous
encore une fois
vraiment on essaie vraiment de vous
donner des commentaires
sans mettre l'ordinateur donc vous avez
juste la jauge par contre déjà on est
obligé de mettre la jauge mais ça
déconcentre bien parce qu'on forcément
par moment je l'oublie et par moment je
la regarde et du coup je deviens focus
jauge quoi et
mais du coup voilà on joue vraiment sans
ordinateur donc on fait des réservoirs
de calcul des fois et puis c'est le jeu
de toute façon eux aussi vous avez bien
vu alors qu'ils sont bien bien plus
forts que nous ce sont des stars
mondiales on a vu il y a eu quelques
bêtises ce soir et de part et d'autre
donc c'est dur pour tout le monde
surtout avec le raccourcissement des
cadres il y a du rythme
avec ce
position ça peut vraiment se casser la
gueule passé qui peut être très pendant
tout à 8 avec un pion qui arrive en 1 ça
pourrait faire très très mal donc en
même temps en 7e aussi donc il y a
plusieurs
humainement on avait peur de spion il va
revenir en E4 peut-être
où je mets mon cavalier en H3 non c'est
nul H3 4 tours 8 par exemple ouais tu
vois il a fini par le mettre en H3
le coup tu vois
mieux là pour les blancs et là ça va
mieux là tu peux même manger le tour là
je pense troisième patient parce qu'il y
a quand même du jeu avec le temps avant
de le faire donc
[Musique]
et attention
on a vu un meilleur visage dans drinkina
cette partie et bien c'est qu'il a fait
une giga connerie avant et ça va
peut-être un petit peu réveiller quand
même parce que là il a été il a été
hyper sérieux
tu vois et je pense que il essaye de
faire un truc bien quoi enfin tu vois il
essaie de créer des choses de s'amuser
en tout cas
alors prends ces deux il y avait des
trois qui perdaient le trou du coup
revient à un point ouais c'est ça
j'ai vu à ce weekend dans une de mes
compagnons d'équipe qui agissent avec
les Blancs
c'est dur ce genre de position les
siennes B3 sur 6 peuvent être très
vénimeuses B6 à très bonne réputation
ouais
mais je connais pas la suite
tour H3
quand ça peut permettre d'attaquer le
roi le roi blanc et du coup là peut-être
que
oui ça commence à chauffer quand même on
dirait une attaque typique
ça va vite ça et ça on dirait un
grand prix à l'envers
par contre ce thème dans cette variante
est très connue avec B5
pour attaquer une fois que le roi à
grand OK
allez André Kin là c'est le moment de
mettre la pression une minute d'avance à
la pendule on gagne avec la noire on
revient à niveau
on fait mal là
je pense que tu vas prendre 10 €
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai
[Musique]
suivi de A5 donc c'est une décision qui
est pas si facile que ça à prendre
[Musique]
tu vois parce que c'est bizarre comme
pause
on avait l'impression de fermer mais
à trois est en prise par le fou et
enjambe aussi que la tour latéralement
et en fait ben
il arrive un petit peu il y a ton
pétrole qui peut
arriverons intermédiaires très très bien
vu de la part de d'aronia
bon après c'est quand même une position
pour essayer de bien saouler
l'adversaire avec le temps
c'est chaud
mais c'est une bonne position pour se
prendre les pieds dans le tapis quand
même que c'est très compliqué mais les
blancs sont comme censés être mieux
mais est-ce que c'est 4 ça reste un gros
un petit C4 qui avait l'aimer six tours
C3 et parfois
qui doit tenir là j'ai pas beaucoup
beaucoup de coups à faire là mais elle a
pas de case
il est pas serein il s'est fait il s'est
fait retourner complet
les pièces jouent plus là il y a pas de
cours c'est très dur de trouver un coup
D6 mais dommage
on y va jusqu'au bout
et comment il va jouer il va manger ça
et de faire
façon maintenant c'est un peu
chaud
l'exécution final
[Musique]
il va manger je pense il est obligé
ouais et
c'est une bonne obligation ici on a tous
les pièces des 4
en l'air le roi il est complètement à
boire et en fait le roi il est bien en
fait vous voyez que Laura blanc il est
ouvert en fait il est très bien tout est
bien
noir sont très ouvertes et du coup on
est les seuls à voir le footcas
noirs qui va arriver aussi F4 aussi F4
là c'est chaud
c'est aussi clairement une idée
c'est un peu un petit peu long mais
c'est une idée
de trouver des coups pour survivre je
pense
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer tour des 8
rois je suis l'idée
un peu
chaude
il a pris G2
[Musique]
pas avoir peur il doit se dire qu'il est
gagnant mais il faut finir et 30
secondes contre 20 donc c'est chaud
de de jouer vite on a peur de gâcher
l'avantage
je pense
tout faire F2
[Musique]
à 4 je joue à 5 à l'arrache sauf 9 x 3
peut-être
[Musique]
c'est hyper chaud comme ça c'est hyper
chaud
allez on prend je la finale
pour les deux joueurs
qui jouent bien avec peu de temps c'est
des oufs
[Musique]
il y a encore pause là
à prendre de l'avance avec les bulles
avant les bulles
il est particulièrement chaud angulaire
il reste au ciné tu as vu il reste au
final
après après à chaque fois on dit ça mais
c'est vrai que
que généralement la dernière fois
car wanna ambulette
je pense qu'il est en train de regarder
comment il a pu rater son attaque et du
coup il a le masque
il a grave envie de savoir pourquoi il a
raté ça
ouais après la pause c'est pas mon
programme pendant la pause parce que tu
vas te lever prendre boire un petit coup
d'eau
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là tu vois
un petit shot un petit chat dans ces
cas-là
et pas vu la derrière
il y a encore une demi-heure de 5
minutes quasiment de de
Blitz en plus une et harmoniaque ça moi
je peux voir sur l'écran en plus
[Musique]
et là il est en train de
je vais
deux heures pour forcément pour pour
tout parce qu'il a gagné à rognon le 5 +
en 3 + 1 il y a il y a encore il y a
encore deux secondes en jeu le 1 + 1 2
sub et la totale c'est 4 seulement plus
donc évidemment maintenant on est obligé
un petit peu
dans le premier set et pour l'instant il
est meneur dans le deuxième stade donc
c'est pas très mérité encore je trouve
heureusement moi
s'accélère ok si les foutu mais sinon
je trouve qu'ils vont hyper vite quoi
c'est à dire que compare à mes
compétences en bullette sauf à chaque
fois punaise incroyable
[Musique]
en plus il se passe pour plein de choses
c'est
plaisant en fait de voir tout ça les
gens sont vraiment extrêmement
merci Robin side parce que il a dit
qu'il allait me coller 10 0 ce soir
voilà André qu'il ne faut pas qu'il me
lâche
déjà il vient de gagner une poubelle
incroyable
ment les tendances
ont tendance à toujours
[Musique]
comment dire s'inverser après les pauses
et donc du coup
là mais bon là il a déjà il a déjà donné
pas mal
n'empêche les matchs sont hyper serrés
qu'on commente
[Musique]
qui était serré et mvl j'ai pas vu en
direct il a rasé il a rasé de népaud de
manière assez convaincante moi j'ai rien
vu de toutes ces matchs c'était pas du
tout chez moi mais j'ai vu j'ai vu que
il y a eu quand même une grosse
différence avec un VL et
mvl et les pots après une époque c'est
un peu spécial parce que tu vois niveau
par exemple qui qui va jouer le match
dans les dates contreding est-ce qu'il a
envie de montrer cette prépa tout ça tu
vois toujours un peu un peu particulier
avec ces gens là
[Musique]
faire un petit résumé pour moi
tranquille ok en fait apparemment en
Viking il regagnait 10 statues depuis le
début de février
et à rognon à historiquement toujours
en bullette avec 34% de chances de de
gain à peu près selon les sondages
et en fait du coup c'est ces espoirs
serait plutôt dans les portions de leads
tout ça quoi
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal honnêtement
très très bien canard tu as bien raison
pour rappeler aux gens un petit peu
ce qui se passe vraiment
sur du 5 + 1 3 + 1 + 1 pour heureusement
qu'elle est tactique tout fin
mais je pense que c'est pire souffre
encore je pense en randoms pour moi
oh ça y est je crois que je commence à
m'habituer en 3-0 tout ça mais par
contre alors tu sais que j'ai fait les
premiers en fait l'autre fois je me suis
dit le vendredi soir je vais analyser
dans mon stream les parties qu'on avait
suivi le mercredi parce que tu sais on
les voit vite fait mine de rien quoi
c'est sympa et après les mecs vont
chauffer pour que
je joue moi-même en Bullet sauf que je
n'avais jamais fait tu vois donc Bullet
en stream j'ai trouvé un mec on sait bon
à 2300 et on a fait quelques bullets
j'ai gagné 5 cartes à l'arrache c'était
dégueulasse voilà c'était c'était ce que
tout le monde veut quoi que tout le
monde voulait je me suis
voilà je me suis prêté au jeu mais
c'était ça là c'était ça
particulier
il est bien motivé je peux te dire que
il vient de se faire un gros shot de
vodka avec sa tasse mais il a trompé
personne
et du coup là il va il va t'envoyer du
lourd
il était bien la présent ils ont pas la
même tête à rognon on a l'impression
qu'il a envie de dormir et en Dream je
crois qu'il a envie de raser là
il a envie
qui va commencer dans quelques instants
le strange le stretching d'arrognan
suffit
allez c'est parti
dans cette deuxième partie du coup de
Blitz en 3 + 1
il arrive pas à jouer et que son temps
c'est cool
du coup
moi j'étais plutôt pour
qu'ils disent problème de sourire tant
pis on joue
s'il a pas mis de pile il a pas mis de
pile ce qu'on avait dit allez c'est
parti 3D 5 il aurait dû jouer cavalier
F3 D5 et moi après ce que jouer le
deuxième Couplan pour réclamer
l'anniversaire de la partie et changer
son rétro beau quoi
t'imagines le filou quoi
et 6 ou B7
il est dans dream
il veut punir un petit peu l'ouverture
de la diagonale blanche avec ces quatre
du coup c'est une bonne tête salut à Flo
et salut chérie
Hello
bienvenue à vous
donc pour jouer vite parce que on a vu
quand même que généralement
scanne bien d'avoir du temps
sur les bonnes cases c'est tout
pour l'instant pas de prise de tête il
joue vite et simple
c'est toujours des choses un peu ça
c'est des besoins qui généralement sont
égales à peu près mais bien sûr engendré
si côté noir quand même et c'est quel
tour du jeu avec comme tu l'as dit avec
des cavaliers ps5 des cases en D6
éventuellement
et du coup il faut être un petit peu il
faut être précis avec les noirs
pour pour réussir à réaliser quoi
en mode Bullet direct en fait il se met
en mode Bullet et puis il met la
pression autant à rognan
c'est pas le réfléchir quoi harmonial de
réfléchir pour égaliser quoi exactement
comme stratégie en tout cas comme comme
pose donc je la réussite comme ça
donc à 6 donc on veut jeter 5 quand même
sur le long terme
il faut
réfléchir maintenant pour perdre du
temps
et moi je suis pour arrogant
[Musique]
de jouer vite et simple
il faut 5 ça menace quoi en fait ça clou
cavalier peut-être un jour tu voudras
manger les fous mais si je dois me
décède par exemple qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on voudrait jouer ici
il faudrait faire trois doubler sur
lacets faire foi F1 tu vois s'il y a pas
beaucoup de points d'entrée
[Musique]
dans mes trois je verrai bien E3 je joue
sur la colonne et je fais fois je vais
essayer de contrôler à l'aile la dame
[Musique]
et l'idée comme tu l'as dit de le 31 et
c'était ramené le fou sur le cadrage
c'est aussi toujours une idée présente
dans ce type de trucs de structure
A4 bécane
mais du coup des fois il y a des idées
avec genre B4 qui avait les B1 à 52 et
même du X 6
pour manger un pion ok ça marchera pas
non c'est un petit peu
[Musique]
et j'en prends bonne note c'est qu'il
met la pression au temps moi ça je sais
pas faire il faut que j'apprenne à faire
ça en Bullet ou partie ultra rapide
ça fait mal quoi
déséquilibre au pire moment pour à
rognan 50 secondes contre une 50 alors
est-ce que ça va suffire j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas c'est la stratégie de
partir est plutôt bien menée si on pense
plutôt au côté pratique justement ouais
c'est ça parce qu'il joue très vite et
il laisse il laisse ça revient
prendre les décisions alors que lui il a
grand chose à prendre comme décision il
y aurait les blancs sont assez simples
depuis le début de partie
tout à fait
en prise en B5 avant de le perdre du
coup
à cette cadence là
donc c'est bizarre mais des idées de
dame peut-être
il veut rentrer ici peut-être
c'est clairement
B2 E3 ah non il y a eu 5 pardon
très dangereux
tu vois ça commence à être les troubles
sur le pion des 5 ou E31
qui commence à
être
c'est plus le même genre que tout à
l'heure il joue mieux en fait il joue
mieux à cette cadence là qu'en 5 + 1
tout à l'heure on est plus spontané on
joue mieux en fait objectivement il est
moins fort
donc je pense que plus la cadence
accélère plus en fait va réussir à
mettre la pression au temps et tout ça
parce que au final
aux échecs mais il est plus instinctif
on va dire ça comme ça quoi
qui est incroyable mais c'est plus un
joueur d'Internet aussi quoi c'est un
joueur qui qui joue sur Internet qui
fait des Bullet tout ça et il est plus
donc à voir en kabyle c'est ça il y a
quand même une menace de fourchette par
exemple je pense qu'il est sérieux
[Musique]
pris en B7 c'est pas très logique mais
voilà
il faut jouer en tout cas là
c'est quand même très très peu
bizarre
c'est pas sur la fonction
je crois
le timing de je pense qu'il a lu
en pire moment et là la partie c'est
tout
je suis pour avoir
cavalier
moi je mangerai je pense que
c'est le cavalier loin
quelque part on voit après
j'ai fait une boulette en plus j'ai
pensé à Dame G7 ou damashe8 alors que la
dame a un contrôlée tu sais ça aurait
été typique de mes parties tu vois ça
extrêmement vite en tout cas donc on
voit quand même un Dream qui prend le
lead dans ce dans ce 3 coussins elle va
dans le match d'ailleurs qui gagne
maintenant d'un point donc il faut une
réaction d'aroniaque qui vient de perdre
je crois
et puis on voyageur ça fait partie du
temps du jeu ce temps là il est en train
de
prendre le large un petit peu une autre
de cette qualité là
et il a changé il a arrêté son petit H3
mais ouais c'est autre chose là
maintenant c'est une position simple
salut Serge s'il fait plus trois ça va
commencer à faire cher et après le 1 + 1
bon
portion c'est un super joueur d'échec
mais c'est clair que et il est pas
mauvais en tout
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
un brigand le gars rognant quoi alors
que les joueurs sont un peu plus
pratique comme tu dis Internet
il veut jouer aux échecs quoi il aime le
beau jeu
[Musique]
qui préfère s'entraîner et faire des
vraies échecs sur un PC qui est
je ne sais pas te dire est-ce que je
n'ai pas la première fois
c'est pas très convaincant ce qui s'est
passé on n'a pas trop de nouvelles de de
fil rouge
donc il doit être en train de bosser en
tout cas et sur un et par ces
championnats ils préparent qui arrive
mais c'est vrai qu'on en a moins de
nouvelles à ces derniers
et il est un peu absent
[Musique]
avec ton bout j'ai tout aussi ça a l'air
assez intéressant cette position mais
Descartes je pense que c'est dans le bon
ton de la position d'essayer de faire
quelque chose je prends là
OK
tu regardes
G4 c'est je pense que tout ça c'est
assez logique
le roi blanc paraît plus
je pense qu'il est né en 83
[Musique]
83 82 84 à 84 vraiment à une année près
83 je sais pas c'est pas en dessous par
an ouais je dirais les 80 83 ou 84
je vous laisse vérifier maintenant
vous avez peut-être
par dessus
pas de chance merci ma poule
il a
cette année
[Musique]
est très très bien les pièces noires
sont toutes rangées
des choses comme ça
c'est rigolo
[Musique]
du coup en fait ça peut toujours
moi je veux bien te reprendre G5
[Rires]
mais pas forcément bon ça c'est quand
même pas mal de pression
on sent qu'elle t'aime avec 30 secondes
c'est le coup qu'on avait envie de jouer
aussi
est-ce que j'ai du carré
à tour Eiffel 5 peut-être pour casser le
lien
j'ai pensé à toi F5 après il a pris
échec
complètement incompréhensible et leur
ordi de langue égale et ça c'est ça j'ai
vraiment beaucoup d'admiration pour ces
joueurs là qui arrive à trouver des
coups dans des positions
pour défendre là quand même ok ouais
c'est maths et comme la montagne
je pense
non tu t'es coincé
surpris par la par la wing de non parce
qu'en fait les deux joueurs c'est des
joueurs qui peuvent tilter et que du
coup ben je pense que c'est avec un gros
score hyper rapide
des joueurs mais en fait bien qu'un gros
score dans un match comme celui-ci d'un
VL contre
ça me paraît pas du tout déconnant parce
qu'en fait parce que même mvl des fois
il a perdu des scores aussi c'est élevés
parce que c'est une genre qui peuvent
tilter et puis bon
[Musique]
pour essayer de jouer plus vite que
l'adversaire
c'est vraiment une position qui va
valoriser la vitesse de jeu
à présent il n'a pas été maladroit dans
ce registre
[Musique]
à trois tours c'est un cavalier A4 fouet
femme
à chaque fois il joue vite et il va
peut-être d'ailleurs ne rien faire dans
cette position
[Musique]
pas faire grand chose je voulais pas
pour nul mais presque et puis si à
rognon se plante il va le il va le
choper
donc c'est rigolo quand même
[Musique]
avec l'idée de faire BK4 essayer de
prendre de l'espace avec la paire de
foot ce côté-là alors peut-être
fou peut-être que sur sur B4 qui fait
encore venir en assassin quand même
c'est ça c'est le risque
cavalier 2 que je
trouve pas très inspirant une des idées
c'est le retour en c1d3 du cavalier ici
pour ces deux ok bah juste il veut pas
se faire refermer
à 4 dames des trois
peut-être B4 maintenant et essayer cinq
positions sont pas faciles et sauf parce
que les noirs
on essaie de bien jouer aux échec de
bien placer les pièces et au final ça
aboutit sur pas grand chose quoi que là
peut-être première
indication faut aller voir sur B3 prend
B3 après trois tourbé 4 peut-être ça
l'idée
qui veut juste manger et ramener les
pièces
donc ça marchera encore mieux peut-être
sur Tours C3 avec un pressing
pour ces trois il y a pas un compte
ancien
de jouer tourbe dans cette position
parce que tu laisses tous les chéquiers
à l'adversaire quoi la colonne qui bouge
pas est-ce que je peux pas jouer
quoi enfin
mais en pratique tu vois t'as pas envie
de donner enfin de te placer comme ça
tu as les Noirs
[Musique]
tu vois il va jouer pour nul en fait
cette partie maintenant qu'il a
ça
une victoire ça peut être ça peut être
quand même sympa
juste pour l'intérieur en fait du mal
c'est pour pour la confiance aussi en
commençant les bullets
bon le fouet du jeu faut faire gaffe
quand même
et là on drague ici il suffit qu'il
passe le cavalier ancien et tu vois dans
le moment chaud là rognon il a perdu 30
secondes alors qu'il avait été toujours
devant
faut qu'il fasse un peu gaffe hein
mais du coup
ok ça c'est un coût raisonnable
mais bon peut-être on peut faire d'un
point à 8 et Tours C5 et cavaliers c'est
un des trois tu vois des choses comme ça
un petit problème dans la position en
plus souffle il faut me faire fouet je
pense qu'il faut manger un fou fou
c'est un moment et je perds la partie là
dessus tu vois
[Musique]
il a mis du temps à jouer 30 secondes
encore
la position n'est pas facile à glissoire
du fou alors ce serait une répète
peut-être
ce que je peux faire mieux que les
choses
en fait il y a pas de ça
du coup
dans ce dans ce match
et ça va faire
ça va faire nul n'a pas trop de raisons
de prendre de resof si vous un truc
concret mais on a du mal à
qu'on peut faire tout seul mais après
faut essayer le problème depuis on B3
vous le voyez tous bon et du coup
qui avance dans ce dans ce match
et donc
la dernière partie on pense
de de 3 + 5 parce qu'il reste 5 minutes
et en tout cas bon il prend pas faire
plus que plus que trois donc du coup
c'est sûr quand Hakim va gagner ce set
et
nul mathématique
après la valeur des 7 enfin il y a pas
de valeur c'est juste pour nous
en fait
au final ce qui compte c'est le score
total c'est pas le 7 tu peux gagner deux
premiers 7
également
donc c'est pas du tout ça qui est en
valeur mais c'est plus pour nous en fait
on va dire parce que nous on parie à
chaque fois qu'on commence ensemble on
parie
qui monte un petit peu nos stream
j'aimerais bien si tu veux sauf que le
sort s'inverse c'est-à-dire que
finalement je sois un peu obligé de
prendre un driking et qui mettent une
grosse tôle à
notre cher ami Levan bah ça ferait bien
plaisir quoi
hello Fatou salut Patou comment tu vas
envoyer les balles
André Kim il est très très chaud
angulette il fait que ça
j'espère qu'il va pas
se voir j'en ai connu d'autre qui était
favoris dans les parties rapides on
avait annoncé un peu vite et après ça
s'est retourné
énormément de choses ça quand même que
finir sur une victoire pour avoir
quand même
grosse prise de risque prend il a joué 4
dans cette position il jouera son
cavalier E5 pour tout au compliquer
[Musique]
c'est compliqué à cette position
préférée OK
5 ce sera pas bon du tout il y aura F5
ça marche pas il y a cavalier
des belles options pour les blancs on
voit quand même que les pièces moi les
cavaliers les fous la dame
c'est intéressant mais
il faut qu'il trouve une idée en tout
cas mal au temps
il faut qu'il trouve une idée donc à 3
il va virer
et là je pense pas qu'il faille changer
je pense qu'il faut garder des pièces
dans 2 et penser à cavaler 5 ans je sais
pas lequel c'est plutôt le cavalier F et
pour l'instant il y a toujours le fond
en l'air à la fin
[Musique]
j'aime pas laisser ma dame en face de la
Tour tu vois il y avait il y a des
vis-à-vis comme ça ça me gêne beaucoup
quand même
et est-ce que c'est le moment balancer
un truc quand j'ai 5
je suis un peu un mode de ligne mais bon
[Musique]
je suis je te prends de moi
une position chaude j'ai plus de temps
la pendule
est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut balancer
les pièces et Kevin qui nous a quitté
les gars
Kevin qui nous a quitté je me disais
bien qu'il parlait pas
Kevin qui va revenir dès que possible
les gars
ou quoi bonjour
laissez tomber à 25 secondes c'est quand
même pas possible donc il a fait qu'un
projet 5
25 secondes à la pendule pour pour
envoyer contre une minute 20 c'est très
très chaud si personne je pense que le
match quasiment scellé parce que avec
trois points de moi il est Bullet qui
arrive c'est malheur très très dur à
remonter alors il s'en foutent il prend
les pions en tous les pions il attaque
le fou ici
et peut-être là peut-être un fou des
cinq avec
bouge c'est chaud
faut virer la lame essayer de d'enlever
la menace du
matin G2 pour pouvoir brûler le cavalier
mais elle est trop mal au temps ça va
perdre en même temps
[Musique]
il arrive à se défendre au final
mais je pense c'est fini hein et le
temps est terminé les gars Kevin revient
on va dire que un tracking il a fait il
a déclaré forfait
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à avoir bien les menaces
des blancs
ok si il prend il part à toi
là il faut commencer à prime
c'est dur cette tour il y a pas de case
[Musique]
j'ai pas le temps de faire pour ramener
madame
[Musique]
il y a une pièce qui va venir à F1
et il arrive à se battre qui va avancer
mais c'est 4 qui aiment très très dur
avec tourner deux tours
c'est très très chaud comme parti mais
bon
mais il faut pousser
je peux manger là faire ça
horrible il y a pas d'échec
horrible
un petit peu malheureusement rien faire
c'est ça va être abondant incroyable
victoire de André Kid dans cette partie
qui
s'appelle
la fin de partie la plus belle parce que
bon
très très vite et ici il a laissé la
dame et après ces deux et ben il peut
pas du tout empêcher la promotion le
pire c'est que si pancary c'est
maintenant qu'en fait et si je viens
défendre là avec le cavalier qui va
défendre c'est juste c'est horrible mais
bon après la position était perdante
pour le blanc
je suis revenu je suis revenu
mais j'étais obligé de de basculer sur
une autre connexion internet pas de
souci grave mais normalement
c'est plutôt cool et alors qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
j'étais vraiment
j'ai une très très grande nouvelle à
t'annoncer
and the king
il a dû il a dû faire forfait pendant le
reste pour le reste du match
du coup le forfait la dernière ronde lui
fait perdre le 7 et aussi perdre le
Bullet
3 + 5 j'ai l'impression
qui
prend un peu
de son de
ce que en fait il me saoule un peu là
je vais essayer de remuer
[Musique]
c'est bon je crois que maintenant vous
entendez plus parce qu'il y avait il y
avait le son chez Ariane
du coup j'ai enlevé tous les zooms
du coup bah écoutez 17 pour pour André
Kim avant le Bullet donc ça promet
d'envoyer un Bullet là rien il faut
qu'il y a plus trois morceaux ça va être
hyper fou de revenir après
un début comme ça
alors il est quand même pas spécialiste
en Bullet alors qu'en vrai King il est
quand même plutôt chaud dans cette
cadence
donc
je donne pas trop cher de la peau de
malheureusement
parce que tu en penses Kévin
c'est clair c'est clair là normalement
je me dis que mon pari est bien lancé tu
vois c'est je peux penser que comme ça
stouf maintenant tu sais bien comment ça
peut se passer des fois la dernière fois
on avait été vraiment surpris bon donc
tout peut arriver encore voilà ce que ce
que je me dis c'est pas encore c'est pas
encore terminé quoi
t'arriver et
c'est pas fini mais après il est vrai
quand même que
dans tous les sens et puis après on
verra moi il y a trois points d'avance
quand même et on attaque la demi-heure
ou le mec a archi favori quoi
de souris ça m'est déjà arrivé ça
souffle
une panneau
filaire et si tu as pas le fil à côté le
temps que tu fais si tu es en 3-0 ou tu
mets 45 secondes aller chercher ton fil
20 à le mettre tu vois autant dire que
que tu as pas gagné ta partie quoi
[Musique]
et du coup j'avais j'avais réussi à
la partie au pad mais bon quand tu fais
pas forcément de pas de là c'est quand
tu as la chance d'avoir un portable moi
fixe tu sais tu as plus de pad et du
coup ça m'a déjà fait ça
pas de papa
moi je sais pas faire non plus
je clavier c'est difficile
et donc là ça va commencer dans quelques
instants
et mais bon après tu as une tête de
souris
[Musique]
en fait c'est pas la faute c'est comme
ça tu perds
c'est la ligne donc
qui se met en place là qui est qui est
prêt en découdre en Bullet
et du coup donc Ariane hurlet noir c'est
parti changer la directement ça
en tout cas elle est chaud André kiné
derrière ce petit sourire il me
paraissait beaucoup plus frais que les
von a rognan et on voit que qu'au final
très clairement ça ça a joué
ça va être dur quand même pour pour les
voies entre clairement ça va être
mission quasi impossible en fait
ça va quand même trois parties remontées
alors que André King est quand même
favori bien favori on a envie de dire
je pense Dimitri nous a pas montrer à
l'écran mais
du coup à chaque ça de gagner il a le
droit à un shot
[Musique]
il peut s'enfiler des burgers il est pas
favori
dans quelques minutes je pense qu'il y
avait des 5 au début donc là
les joueurs avant
pour jouer le Bullet
lorsqu'on assis
quand on pue l'arbitre du coup parce que
j'ai coupé
et du coup je pense que ça va ça va
arriver bientôt
en cas d'égalité en Bullet en cas
d'égalité sur le score final il y aura
des partages donc il y aura quatre
parties
de Bullet si Ali si les quatre parties
de Bullet et ben on a encore égalité il
y aura un
match arnaque et donc
des sortes de
d'enchères pour terminer le temps sur
lequel ils vont jouer c'est un peu
bizarre
on n'a pas encore vu
donc en tout cas on essaiera de
l'expliquer en temps venu si ça arrive
on voit que dans mine de rien dans ce
truc là il faut faut être le meilleur
possible en Bullet c'est ça que c'est ça
qui compte à la fin quelle bonne chance
que 5 + 1 3 + 1 c'est équilibre mais
après le 1 + 1 ça fait trop la
différence
entre trois puissants et en 5 + 1 on a
vu carolienne il a pris cher quand même
6 2 encore plus simple et donc c'est
c'est chaud
en fait il a pas besoin de respecter
véritablement les codes des joueurs on
va dire de haut niveau en drekin il joue
juste très rapidement sans faire de
grosses conneries et mets une pression
de dingue autant quoi c'est ça
il joue vite et après bon c'est un jour
à 2700 plus donc c'est un joueur qui est
très très bien qui a un très bon
instinct mais c'est vrai que
au-delà de ça il a un style et je très
solide et très vite et il pose des
problèmes pratiques et
essayer de chercher perpétuellement la
vérité parce qu'il est capable de la
trouver dans les positions mais
malheureusement avec ce temps imparti
c'est dur quoi c'est ça malheureusement
c'est il est perfectionniste
il a du mal à vraiment
on peut trouver allez c'est parti donc
enreging blanc votre première partie
donc qui rejoint
mais il a bouffé 10 secondes déjà
[Musique]
3 et après E4 peut-être là j'ai envie de
jouer fouf 4 et C4 peut-être F3 et le C4
peut-être ou le 4 du plaisir du plaisir
du plaisir c'est carte peut-être là
il a fait tourcien préventif mais c'est
très bien
cette position il y a 23 secondes contre
une minute quand même on va voir s'il va
tenir le choc pour une fois
le plus vite mais il a une poubelle
il prend des cartes
pour trois peut-être
en tout cas
allez tours
on va jouer final finalement ranger
71 pas facile là quand même mais en
seconde contre 40 il faut qu'il joue à
chaque fois tempo
inactive il a raté tout un je crois sauf
qui gagne la partie
[Musique]
les surprises prises coup franc il y a
un match du couloir
jusqu'au bout c'est encore et un peu de
travail
au niveau de sa gestion de parti va
gagner
il faut encore
c'est chaud à chaque fois c'est de la
très très chaud
pas comment on continue comment on passe
bien joué super bien joué
incroyable
c'est sûr à un moment donné
de toute façon il avance
chaque échec voilà allez bonne partie en
tout cas
avec notre vue pour le Bullet est-ce que
vous préférez les gars est-ce que vous
préférez un petit plaisir est-ce que
vous préférez cette vie là pour les
pour les pour les buettes on les voit
mieux les joueurs on ne voit plus
est-ce que vous préférez ça ou est-ce
que vous préférez l'autre parce que
comme c'est du Bullet ça va vite
peut-être que vous préférez avoir un
petit peu vraiment les expressions des
joueurs
dites-nous ce que vous préférez en tout
cas dans le chat comme comme caméra
peu de variété allez un peu de variété
je pense que ça va finir sur un kif-kif
tu vois ce genre de question on se
trouve
on est plus beau c'est vrai qu'on est
plus Beau
c'est mieux ça mais en fait ouais je
crois que les gens ils veulent pas nous
voir
on va garder cette petite
[Musique]
on fait de la radio finalement OK
et à chaque fois que je change de scène
ça me met à condition et je dois changer
de scène pour que ce soit les bonnes
caméras donc malheureusement je ne peux
rien y faire c'est pas moi qui m'occupe
de tout ça
donc il faut se les prendre les
transitions je suis désolé
c'est sympa
en 18 bon je comprends très bien en tout
cas ce que tu moi quand je vais régler
le truc c'est pareil à chaque fois que
je changeais de scène je me posais la
transition
donc moi ça m'a saoulé
en tant que
il se fait bien masteriser pour
l'instant dans le Bullet
d'un F2 ouais là pour l'instant et tu
vois c'est à chaque fois ce qu'on dit
le joueur qui est pas populaire qui est
pas bon ils sont très fort mais le
joueur qui est le moins fort angulaire à
chaque fois galère
moi
j'ai pas me comparer sur là mais je vois
un match contre Sabrina Vega tu dois
connaître
le numéro 1 espagnol et en fait
le match était assez chaud et dès qu'on
arrive en Bullet elle m'a explosé alors
que dans sa vie elle avait fait
je sais pas 5 cibulettes dans sa vie et
moi des bullets j'en ai fait des
plusieurs centaines de milliers quoi
et je l'ai battu en 5 + 1 alors qu'il
perdrait en Bullet quoi alors clairement
c'est l'inverse
un peu après le fait de mettre un crime
angulaire c'est un peu bizarre aussi
c'est un petit peu différent du coup
alors moi je suis pour un rognan
[Musique]
il y a du monde
je suis désolé les gars il le faut à
chaque partie il faut que je chante la
scène
et on repart sur la prochaine partie
salut Emmanuel
7 tu vois les vannes et du coup André
kiné que c'était pas bon ce qu'il avait
joué les vans c'est déjà réadapté quoi
c'est fou les mecs
[Musique]
confiant et là maintenant tout est
relancé quoi salut les amis
[Musique]
on est pour qui moi j'ai parié sur sur
Aronian c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
un match on
un petit Paris pour essayer de mettre un
petit peu de piment tout ça et donc moi
j'ai parlé sur aronia
j'ai choisi en premier parce que dans
les matchs c'est Kevin qui avait choisi
et c'est là où je me suis fait avoir
je voulais prendre un magazine donc et
là bon
en fait les deux matchs sont vraiment
[Musique]
sans vraiment vraiment pas clair quoi
c'est chaud tu vois si on prend ma
caméra et et par avion en vrai celui qui
prend par avion il est pas bien néo
Paris je pense qu'il va faire une grosse
crotte
d'ailleurs les les sites
sondages ça donnait 99% 98% je crois
pour
ma caméra
[Musique]
en 55 ans
quand tu es vraiment meilleur dans ces
cadences là
il y a pas trop de
joueur mais c'est en 2006 quoi oui c'est
ça c'est pas le même jeu
qui est passé dans notre chat sauf il
est créateur de jeux
il m'a fait découvrir un jeu cet été
pendant un championnat de France
où il était présent le dictopia
super jeu très familial en plus donc
[Musique]
j'aime bien jouer en plus
je sais bien je sais bien tu aimes bien
parier tout ça donc vraiment là ça peut
être l'occasion et
là on voit le pion a qui s'envole non
contrôle et puis on sait qu'il n'est pas
parti
il a oublié
tu gagnes d'un processus encore plus
simple
un jeu qui qui vaut le qui vaut le
détour donc c'est bien normal
je me suis vraiment amélioré en plus que
j'avais été un peu modeste à ce jeu là
au début de l'ordre des découvertes
souffle faut attendre d'adaptation tu le
sais bien
mais en tout cas non non super je donc
dictopia René Le dictopia ça marche
vraiment cool plus un jeu rapide quoi tu
vois donc du coup tu peux pas des
longueurs à des longueurs
[Musique]
ça marche pas
dans quel sens
parce que il y aura un problème
il pourrait être pénible donc faut
trouver quelque chose qui arrive
faire ah j'ai 5 du coup
il joue comme ça
[Musique]
après souvent c'est dans le money time
où les mecs continuent à être hyper
rapide tu vois les vrais les vrais mecs
qui jouent comme ça c'est la danse là
[Musique]
il y a des petites
surtout le Time deux fois plus de taille
il est hyper rapide
mais faut 4 après il y aura F3 à un
moment donc c'est pas trop grave
c'est facile
un peu pénibles à gagner donc du coup
peut se passer des trucs regarde la
petite pour eux aussi
il veut pas manger il va amener ça tout
en G6 et faire un beau vol dame j'ai
trois malin
un peu galère à gagner quand même à 9 10
secondes tu vois ça peut être
ça peut être une bonne embrouille cette
position pas mal ça peut-être d'abord
tout
c'est chaud c'est chaud faut pas
s'arrêter là de
clairement
une presque nulle il y a eu il y a eu un
moment mais c'est de passer tellement
vite
qui revient vraiment
assez pas vrai quoi
j'espère que tu vas pas me faire une
tarification maison de 8,2 tu sais
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
allez il reste 14 minutes il était à -3
et plus qu'à -1 il a fait plus que la
moitié du job
c'est le moment
ça y est il est il est chaud maintenant
il est chaud il s'est bien déchargé
c'était vraiment très passif
mais c'est dur pour les joueurs par
moments soufflé ils se prennent des
salves de points alors que c'est des
joueurs qui ont l'habitude de gagner
mais dans ce format là de jouer autant
de parties contre un mec aussi fort en
face la même eux ils ont pas tant que ça
l'habitude en fait
donc parmi ça peut faire bizarre d'en
perdre 38 quoi tu vois c'est ça peut
vite arriver quoi clairement alors que
bon la proba est pas hyper grande au
départ
qui joue vraiment très très vite et ça
c'est vrai que c'est appréciable
il faut jouer vite et au hasard voilà
franchement
ok maintenant faut trois fous d'écart on
va vite on n'en peux plus c'est bien je
vous ai 5 ça empêche ça peut-être mais
quatre prises
attention attention
ça fait toujours du bien
s'il prend qu'elle va dépendre qui va
tomber
pas trop échanger
à la fin des 7 c'est pas simple
attention
est-ce que je joue au 3 ou pas
pour ces 7 bien joué je pense
franchement qu'est-ce qui nous régalent
les pions
voilà courbe qui est descendue qui
remonte c'est très chaud des deux côtés
et chaque échec ramasse le fou
qui va
c'est terrible là un tour des deux
cette position
[Musique]
c'était chaud hyper chaud
incroyable
[Musique]
allez il faut lui coller là
incroyable ils font des
parents
incroyables monstrueuses quoi ça c'est
écrit tellement de choses super il y a
juste un moment dans le 5 + 1 deuxième
partie où c'était vraiment pas terrible
et c'est pas drakking d'ailleurs qui
commence à vraiment mal joué et là
rognan il a une belle réaction d'orgueil
dans le 3 + 1 je pense qu'il a été trop
lent pas assez pratique il a voulu
vraiment bien jouer aux échecs et dans
le 1 + 1 il est beaucoup plus pratique
c'est vraiment beaucoup mieux il essaie
pas de pas se laisser faire autant quoi
et ça marche bien de toute façon on n'a
pas le choix
donc là il reste 10 minutes 9 minutes
maintenant il faut il faut une réaction
de suite là
et là il a pris 10 secondes dans la vue
en plus avec ce bon vieux dame C8 dégueu
mauvaise nouvelle cavalier 5 trop
pénible on sait plus quoi jouer avec les
noirs
tour B8 à l'arrache KD-8 à l'arrache
tout des 4 la avec plein de trucs en 8
fois 6 pareil
on est à deux doigts tout de suite
il est fou André King
dépité
de regarder non regarde pas de bien ce
qui va t'arriver
G5
[Musique]
fois tu me fais le coustouf hein
toi tu me fais le même coup à chaque
fois quoi c'est terrible quoi tu
m'annonces que le mec il va se faire
avoir une telle cadence et en fait pas
jamais comme ça en fait je ne comprends
pas
ça pour bouiner
dans les positions
alors entendre le match de couloir bien
sûr voilà
ça a pas marché
il pourrait abandonner mais en fait dans
ce match walking juste le petit but
juste le temps s'écoule pour essayer de
marquer le plus de points c'est
parti pour qui moins de partie derrière
conviction personnelle il en a déjà
arnaqué je pense plusieurs en là c'était
trop
[Musique]
allez du coup c'est reparti 11,5
points quoi je me disais qu'avec peu de
chance quand même
c'est un petit peu enfin les gens se
défendent comme des comme des chiens
va être va être
le bon choix
inspiré en plus je sens bien donc c'est
quoi c'est
c'est l'avant avant-dernière celle-là
un réveille-toi en Drake Insan faut pas
la première sinon
non on est rasé
a été confiant Drake
ils peuvent prendre des cas prendre B5
c'est chaud tout est chaud ils laissent
tous ces pions prises en Dream et il y
en a un qui a fini par sauter je crois
que c'est chaud je crois que je ne
comprends pas le micro
à 5 derrière en plus
pas de raison qu'il soit mieux position
est très ouverte sur 15 blanche
et à rognon le pilone mais bon il y a le
temps le temps c'est très très important
on l'a dit encore un pion pour passer
un des jeux aux échecs c'est le jeu de
la promotion on l'a beaucoup vu là en B6
il est intéressant de faire tourner un
et avoir la pression sur B7 quelques
secondes d'avance pour Android est-ce
que ça a suffire pour embrouiller
[Musique]
désolé pour les cours je crois que ça
devrait mieux marcher maintenant comme
ça
à moins que
je fais des
c'est bon il paraît que c'est bon
c'est chaud
André King tente le tout pour le tout
oh là là
attention
les vannes à légèrement fauté
et il va quand même tenir cette position
il reste 3 minutes donc du coup après
cette partie il risque d'y avoir iris
d'y avoir
une dernière partie
cette position encore donc on va voir si
on aura le droit une ou deux parties ah
c'est vrai que ça se termine après
3 minutes là dessus il y aura encore une
ou deux parties ouais alors si égalité
elle a dit non ça va se jouer il y aura
quatre parties de Bullet et si Alice le
4 parties il y a encore égalité
et ben
[Musique]
c'est quoi l'idée là
c'est encore égalité et Ben
et ben il y aura une partie Armageddon
donc une dernière partie pour terminer
ça c'est nul mais ils ont plus de temps
tous les deux côtés
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire
à bloquer un petit peu le roi blanc il
me fait un peu peur là
un peu peur
[Musique]
ah oui sublime
souffle allez allez
qu'on gagne cette partie un peu plus
égaliser le 7 on peut plus égaliser le 7
ouais
ou pas est-ce que vous voulez le tie
brique tie-break dites le nous on veut
le tie-break on veut le tie-break on
veut carrément gagne cette partie c'est
sûrement la dernière partie tournoi et
du coup Dimitri André Kim qui pourrait
qui pourrait aussi
faire durer la partie tu vois en cas de
fous de couleur opposé ou un truc comme
ça il pourrait faire
il doit faire durer il doit faire durer
plein de joueurs comme Nakamura etc
faudrait pas faudrait pas exagérer on a
quelques-uns motivés
donc je pense qu'elle est prête à
attendre un petit peu
ouais le vin son altablo du speech à la
fin peut-être après cette partie
peut-être après la victoire on va voir
mais on mettra après cette partie quoi
qu'il arrive il y aura une pause quoi la
pause tie-brac soit soit la fin du match
et on mettra le tableau le Vince
c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est chaud
ouais il est pas très très bien rognant
pour moi dans cette position mais bon
parce qu'en fait il reste 40 secondes
vous voyez en haut il y a le timer et si
on arrive à zéro et ben ça veut dire que
c'est la dernière partie là c'est parti
on G5 sans doute
Alger c'est fort mais il y aura qui
avait les G5 oulala il prend tous les
risques ah non il y a fou des 6 pardon
et
c'est très très chaud quand même
trois tours F3
gagne cette partie les gars on a les
départages s'il y a rien ne gagne pas
cette partie et ben sera terminé
en tout cas c'est pas vrai il était bien
vous êtes trop bien aussi
cavalier F5 c'est quand même pas la sécu
ce qu'il a joué je trouve mais bon
allez on y va là
on le carotte E5 elle abandonne Dimitri
abandonne on a fait une autre j'allais
donner mon four moi comme affiche
[Musique]
génial
je suis en train de me vanter là
allez cavalier le cavalier il doit faire
des galop là
par contre faut jouer là
machin très très bien joué
très bien
jouécis
tranquille on prend un 7 pièces
je vous donne des quatre bon il donne ça
comprend C4
parce qu'ils vont expliquer un peu ce
qui se passe
voilà j'avais ouvert le son de zoom
et ça va être
terminé du coup 12 et demi 12 et demi
non là ils vont annuler la partie
et du coup 12 amis nous ennemis donc
c'est quand même le premier départage
attends une seconde hein je vais
parler une seconde OK
c'est à partir donc en gros c'est du
Bullet au début ils ont annoncé que
c'était du 1 + 0 et on va André Kim le
grand sourire était content et
final non désolé c'est un plus un et du
coup il y a quatre parties donc le truc
à 2 et demi gagne si à l'issue des
quatre parties ben c'est match nul et
ben il faut un magazon donc on va un
petit peu ce que ça donne
dans tous les cas voilà tu vas rajouter
un 7 dans ta dans ta scène sauf ou pas
bah est-ce que tu veux
un plus un
ah c'est parti en plus
je suis à 4 2 1 4 2 4 2 et la dernière
fois c'était 8 2 donc pour me refaire je
suis malade il faut faire vite là allez
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
tout à l'heure et à rognon que je voyais
fatigué
par contre j'aime pas regarder les
résultats à 5 4 2 6 et là à rognon
arrive en place étroit mais j'aime
vraiment pas le fait de de d'avoir cette
pause là parce qu'à rognan il est
vraiment dans un bon un bon rêve et là
il va repartir quoi donc
ce qui est normal
elle est normalement de Reiki il a quand
même une expérience de situation
un petit gilet de pêche tu m'as dit que
chasseur il me fait penser d'ailleurs au
maillot officiel de l'équipe de
Vandoeuvre tous les ans en 2016 l'équipe
de vendeur
ils ont un petit gilet de pêche qui est
assez sympa aussi et c'est bien d'en
faire la promo
quatre parties s'il y a 3-0 je pense
qu'ils en font pas quoi allez allez
Mario
en tout cas je peux te dire que j'ai un
peu décomposé quand j'ai entendu que
c'était du 1 + 0
je sais pas en fait
après je sais pas je dis ça mais j'en
sais rien
et j'ai l'impression que les gens
s'écrivent tiens on a vu que André Kim
qui a dit un truc qui a tapé un truc
avec son clavier et qui a rigolé il a
encore que aronia doit aussi rigole et
tape un truc je pense que les joueurs
tchat entre eux en tout cas comme je
suis arrivé je suis arrivé à l'avance
sur zoom j'ai vu que les joueurs se
parlaient ils se demandait un petit peu
comment ça va la vie etc qui parlait en
russe donc je comprenais rien ce qu'il
disait mais ils avaient l'impression de
parler un petit peu enfin de prendre un
peu de nouvelles l'un de l'autre donc
s'apprécient dans le circuit bien sûr et
donc voilà en tout cas c'est sympa cette
petite offre non
bah il arménien donc j'imagine qu'il
doit parler un petit peu
une langue qui se rapproche peut-être du
russe je sais pas trop
mais bon il a arménien après
mais il parlait une langue qui m'est
complètement inconnu
le russe à l'école
d'ailleurs on a où est le collège fuck
oui qui parle russe également je crois
sur le chat pas mal
d'ailleurs je vois pas ta petite épée
[Musique]
pourquoi tu l'as pas l'épée
impatiemment il a envie d'en découdre
mais le smile mais j'espère les gens ils
en ont marre en même temps c'est à dire
qu'il y a de la ligne c'est un peu le
tout qui se mêle dans ces moments-là
c'est ça ils ont envie d'en finir
surtout tu vois de jouer aux échecs ça
se finisse ça se finisse bien
il y aura qu'un gagnant OK
allez ça va commencer
ils vont lancer la première partie et
ensuite les joueurs vont vont se défier
à revenir comme ça mais c'est là qu'on
voit qu'ils sont tous forts c'est un peu
le même cas d'accord Fabiano qu'on avait
pu le commentaire
et du coup ils arrivent à sortir
là ils peuvent en prendre trois quatre
de suite après ils reviennent avec allez
c'est parti je sais pas si vous voyez il
est parti
je vais devoir vous changer le ou
changer la
la truc désolé 5 secondes les gars je
suis vraiment désolé
mais sinon vous allez vous tromper de
couleur
je suis vraiment désolé pour les scènes
c'est pas moi qui l'ai faite c'est fait
pour
très bien mais c'est vrai que la
transition de 5000 à chaque fois ça peut
gênant tout ambulette donc il y a plus
de chrono maintenant c'est au meilleur
des quatre parties il faut marquer deux
points et demi et c'est gagné
un Dimitri t'as les blancs
3 tu échanges les fous tu massacres le
pion C7 tu gagnes la partie
on propose l'échange des dames
et maintenant et maintenant il faut voir
si ça arrive un jour
parce que j'espion rirer et je peux pas
leur débarrasser
le cavalier qui va nous faire gagner
cette position
H3 c'était un peu modeste
je vois pas comment pas m'améliorer la
position mais en même temps c'est pas
facile de passer pour
échanger pour gagner la casse B5 c'est
bien vu ça c'est tout enfin pas facile
mine de rien de gagner avec les Blancs
non plus
je sais pas si j'aurais laissé rentrer
la tour B3 peut-être tout simplement
ouais puis à 5 à B6 il y a D5
potentiellement en l'air des 5 menaces
de couloir
c'est fait c'est pris attention en pion
F2 qu'on ne peut pas protéger peut-être
tomber deux tout simplement le coup du
professionnel ou pas tomber de
tomber de voilà en tout cas il faut
prendre son temps tu as raison André
King c'est le moment de prendre son
temps
il faut que je te résote là il y a pas
un échec échec ou un truc comme ça là
mais là du coup l'action qui va filer là
c'est parti
donc du coup
du coup ouais
bien joué
c'est quoi cette histoire
incroyable cette partie incroyable à
regarder ça c'est ça c'est hyper bien
parce que franchement allez
il reste 3 parties
la grosse cagoule
ça il y a pas grand chose
cavalière aussi
les petits rocs
en plus là cette pollution elle est elle
est bonne pour les blancs tu vois qu'il
y a moyen de presser un peu avec un
cavalier en dessin
allez non B3 je suis pas fan mais fou le
sac c'est intéressant c'est tout petit
c'est tout petit
rassuré
normalement ça devrait bien se passer on
a gagné les gars
[Musique]
[Rires]
si on joue vite normalement il peut rien
se passer
j'aime pas les trois gamins je suis pas
fan et trois qui empêche qu'avec ces
trois quand même ça me rassurerait un
petit peu voilà merci pour moi
attention à la fourchette quand même
marché fais attention
comme moi on a vu la jauge dès que c'est
le coup de souffle
il faut défendre
ah j'aime pas ce qui se passe là j'aime
pas trop ce qui se passe là tout d'un
coup naturel
prend E5 et on lui pique son cavale
tellement important
il me force à faire aider cinq je joue
les bonnes décisions
j'y comprends rien ça va trop vite
belle fin j'avoue allez bon maintenant
tu as encore une fois en balle de match
ça revient tu sais que tu es imbattable
dans ce match imbattable à Rognac c'est
maintenant qu'il faut marquer
de la filet
blanc voilà super best indienne là de
Levon si personne là regarde c'est
terminé s'ils font encore faire une
dernière partie allez tu as les Noirs tu
ne peux pas perdre juste tu ne peux pas
perdre c'est chaud c'est très très chaud
comme Mathieu
c'était sympa franchement ils nous ont
régalé les joueurs maintenant
on fait on joue le jeu hein
ton temps
il faut quand même bien finir ce match
c'est quand même dommage de Blender pour
pas avoir réfléchi
qui peut se réveiller
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est
après c'est terrible après ils ont pas
le temps les mecs
celui-là c'est cadeau
punaise le fou va se réveiller ça va
être 5 le foot 15 secondes je vais
sortir un jour il a fait mais il doit
pas en revenir lui-même de ce qu'il a
fait
non
c'est gratuit
c'est la clé c'est la clé
s'appelle stuff merci quoi
on sort les pièces cette partie
normalement ne devrait pas toucher un
pion en C4 qui bloque le four
il fait une
allez fous bouge non non je suis pas sûr
peut-être que c'est quand même
il ne tient pas la pression on voit ça
hein il tient pas la pression
on a l'impression qu'il est parti comme
quand je suis en Bullet là des trucs où
tu laisses toutes tes pièces en prises
et puis voilà
c'est parti moi ça arrive
la déception mais ça va tellement vite
ils sont fatigués les joueurs aussi vous
voyez qu'on commence à donner des pièces
nous aussi quand on fait les
commentaires bah c'est pareil eux ils en
donnent pas d'ailleurs mais ils font
quelques faut continuer il faut pas il
faut pas blondir hein
l'ordinateur il fait pas la gueule là
non ça va mais
oh là là le bol
le gros bol mais Ronan il fait un peu la
gueule mais il y a quand même les pions
qui avance là
les rois G7
c'est pas fini encore
ou des deux
j'avoue que j'ai transpiré
la partie largement mais c'est vrai
qu'il a eu un bon coup de bol en driki
est vert je vous ai changé le truc parce
que du coup la partie est terminée donc
bien joué le changement il se laisse
tomber
il se laisse tomber et du coup dernière
partie du coup maintenant avec du coup
s'il y a un résultat et Ben et ben le
gagnant gagne
c'est reparti
ce sera le
c'est maintenant qu'on joue c'est pas
vrai tu vas pas me faire ça pas deux
fois on a des blancs
mais alors là c'est dans l'extrême
moneytime
maintenant et après gagner là tu me
sidérais de faire ça aurait été mieux de
finir la partie avec le perpète de tout
à l'heure de la première partie de tes
partages
terribles oui c'est vrai que celui-là
contre un mine de rien parce que il
racontait
il faut que j'invite la rognan faut pas
stresser il faut jouer vite
c'est pas ça reste un tournoi Internet
etc il y a une petite pression qui se
met des fois ben bien sûr qu'il y a une
pression il y a du Bullet c'est chaud
hein
tu veux faire derrière mais j'ai fou de
tête
un petit coup cette foulée 3 en influant
j'aime pas il y a toujours des peut-être
du coup peut-être plutôt fou F1 au fouet
allez c'est un peu en plus là
allez papa allez papa
il faut que je visite par contre
qu'est-ce que c'est cavalier
pas du tout à s'embrouille
on joue tout bien et on fait une grosse
cagette
joue je joue quoi
[Musique]
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a pourquoi
non mais c'est bon je suis là
non
oui c'est gagné quoi
[Musique]
on y va
en vrai il nous régale parce que à la
fin ils font ils jouent aussi mal que
nous en fait en fin de partie
il faut réussir à passer le four
oui c'est terminé
quel match en tout cas
il avait maté
deux secondes il joue le gilet
[Musique]
il était mat non mais en fait ce qu'il
aurait dû faire c'est qu'il aurait dû
manger
il est fâché il s'en va direct
parce qu'en fait bon après il y a eu
plein de parties où il y a eu des
retournements quand même tu vois
il joue le dernier coup un peu pour
rester en vie mais en fait oui mais un
rognon je pense qu'il a juste oublié de
faire un projet 4 quoi dans cette
position il a envie de faire à changer
quatre
vraiment là c'était quand même petite
pression noire quand même maintenant bon
après bon c'est assez rigolo l'histoire
et après du coup après ça
il pensait mater un paragrade mais il a
oublié ça casse pour le roi quoi et du
coup au lieu de faire ça bah juste tu
manges de cadre et puis et puis manger
deux et puis tu vois et sur rage prend
non mais c'était pas
encore si clair
en situation je vous enlevé les caméras
parce que du coup ça fait un peu moche
là on voit plus rien ils font tous un
peu bizarre
c'est pas vrai le 8 de 2 x 8,2
et du coup bah écoute
très très gros match en tout cas
d'aronyan qui gagne quasiment dans un
magasin qui viennent de partage et
franchement on a bien vibré dans ce
match en tout cas moi je suis assez
content de mon petit Paris encore Kevin
qui me rapporte encore 800
supplémentaires
on a combien du coup alors je vais te
dire la date est importante
alors du coup
et ouais 8 8 et 4 donc pas seul
va payer
[Rires]
en fait
donc en fait
parce que ils sont ils font que de
parler derrière ça m'énerve
on se on s'amuse trop du coup prochain
match ce sera du coup la semaine
prochaine on a mardi donc ça va être
sûrement Kevin Bordy qui va qui va le
commenter sur sur la chaîne tchatche
comme fr donc ça va être Carcès contre
kookesh
et en plus du coup enfin et derrière on
aura des matchs mercredi jeudi et
vendredi donc toute la semaine prochaine
quasiment tous les jours on aura des
matchs de speechess pour vous régaler
ouais donc en tout cas en tout cas merci
à vous vraiment d'avoir suivi d'avoir
suivi le stream avec nous et puis on
vous dit à la semaine la semaine
prochaine et puis encore une fois bien
sûr si vous voulez nous rendre visite
sur nos sur nos sur nos chaînes
respectives je vous mets le lien
on vous remercie en tout cas c'était
cool bonne ambiance dans le chat c'est
assez animé et du coup la mienne je peux
pas vous la faire mais si quelqu'un peut
me faire un saut malheureusement je peux
pas le faire moi surtout c'est surtout
c'est stream nous retrouver sur nos
chaînes respectives avec avec grand
plaisir pour animer ça comme vous le
faites ici quoi
voilà et quand tu fais sauce tout ça
fait une Pro Évolution ma chaîne est là
voilà si vous voulez nous rejoindre
après sur nos selles ce sera grand
plaisir en tout cas nous on va partir
avec un petit raid on va se faire un
petit raid
avec notre ami oups
notre ami
thévernante les gars c'est un super
streamer franchement il fait du bon
boulot il est très très sympa donc
ouais les Bretons donc allez le rendre
visite ça va lui faire plaisir et en
plus ouais donc c'est un raid échec il
est hyper sympa il est hyper cool
vraiment chill donc vraiment je pense
que pour ceux qui le connaissent pas en
tout cas vous découvrir un mec très
sympa donc en tout cas je vous dis merci
à tous d'avoir suivi de stream merci à
toi Kevin et à la semaine prochaine très
plaisir même si tu m'as rasé au final
refaire c'est ça c'est ça j'ai mal
commencé mais je finis bien
donc merci à tous les gars j'ai envoyé
le raid qui devrait partir maintenant
dans quelques secondes donc je vous dis
des gars à très très bientôt merci
encore à tous pour pour tout ça pour
toute cette compagnie et
dormez bien c'est ça bon soirée
yes à bientôt ciao les gars ciao bye
ciao ciao